what kind of waveform are we making
today
let's make a penis waveform
this is like squid game
no it's not
it says a lot about society you can't
you can't just say something is like
something you say just like everything
is like squid game that's like humor now
that's what makes me laugh what's what's
the meme well i i don't get the meaning
what's the punch line there's no that's
the point it's like poo poo stink so
it's like an anti-joke yeah yeah exactly
yeah well this says a lot about society
there's a lot of says a lot about
society when i have to explain an
anti-joker
it says a lot of us so i just
it's just like peter griffin just like
leaning over in black and white and it's
like this this is a lot about society
this does say a lot about society that
that has become that that has become a
meme says a lot about society i don't
know why i mean i'll i'll be bored of it
by the time this episode
like there are some anti-jokes that i
get and then there are some that are
just like this this this this isn't even
bass boosted how can you find it funny
like give it a day and you'll be
laughing like that
welcome society to another
trash can
it says a lot when i have to open a
trash days episode like that
i say i don't think it says enough i am
society member number one with two more
members of society
hello hello hello you know what says a
lot about society the fact that we don't
watch happening
so you see now you're laughing at the
joke so now you're laughing at the
church i'm just laughing at how [ __ ]
that [ __ ] segway did you just like
speed run titular titles i think so i
think so okay for once we uh got in a
pretty interesting discussion before we
started turning on the cameras and we
were like wait wait wait wait wait same
for the episode we should turn on the
cameras before we start yeah talking
we're talking about society i can't i
can't calmly believe we have a
conversation and didn't try to monetize
them what the [ __ ]
i just don't talk i'm a professional
podcaster
i was basically ranting how uh i don't
watch anime nowadays because i mean you
guys know that anyway yeah but that's
not a revelation but i think a lot of
people think it just because like i've
fallen out of it it's not that it's that
like i find so much anime just so
goddamn boring now i just find it's not
even about it being boring it's just
redundant
like i just feel like it really says a
lot about society it's oh my god see he
laughed see you like the meme
okay why does it say a lot about society
jerry i want to hear your inspiration
it's just he was gonna say he was gonna
say he says a lot about anime yeah
i was gonna say it really says a lot
about anime but then the moment i said
it really says a lot it just like it was
like
it was like that was like the 100
unintentional pun
i support this okay it really says a lot
about anime when i read
when i
when all it takes is for me to read a
synopsis and i could probably tell you
with 90 accuracy what the first three
episodes of that anime is going to be
about yeah yeah and you know and not
even in like a like an arty farty
general type of way like in in a
detailed way yeah i would like to
preface as we have to preface every
argument you know there is always like
one or two shows that are good
entertainment no all anime sucks like
there's just
so much like mediocre stuff that is so
un uninspired and just rehashing of what
we've seen before and just just kind of
jumping off successful characters and
premises we've had before like i've seen
a joey earlier i was like there's so
many characters now i feel like i've
watched so many anime like i get the
power fantasy ones right yeah
but like
i understand that the point is is that
they're meant to be all powerful and
they can't [ __ ] up yeah
but like is that always that fun like is
that always like great like sometimes
i'm like can you have like a floor or
something like something that makes you
a little human so i'm not like bored out
of my mind watching you no because
sidetime is bold right that's a flower
that's like i can relate
no i get it because it's like
the but that's the problem right is that
i think the reason why power fantasies
are just they make the most like
quote-unquote perfect main characters is
because it if they had flaws it would
completely go against the point of being
a power fantasy it's like why would i
want to self-insert myself into this
all-powerful character if this
this character that is supposed to be
the better version of me also makes
mistakes right i get that but at the
same time it's like okay that's fine if
you're self-inserting but not every
person who watches shows like that
wants to self-insert they just want to
watch a character that is completely
independent from them go through this
adventure or whatever right but i don't
know it's i mean i mean i i feel like i
i'm like the spokesperson for like that
that kind of animation and i'm just like
yeah i completely recognize that
it's it's the the problem with anime
nowadays is that one there is so much of
it
and number two a lot of it is what i
just call call disposable shows where
it's just not even like a show anymore
it's just content it's just something
you consume right so that's what that's
how i view a lot of visa guys right the
reason i watch a lot of visa guys
because it's exactly the same thing not
i'm not going to remember most of them
but i get the same kind of experience
it's it's the it's why i like it's why
it's the same region as what i see
people watching you know quote unquote
trash tv shows for like trash reality
shows like you know you know what you're
getting with say you know you know
kitchen nightmares or hell's kitchen or
you know something along those lines
where it's just a repeatable format you
know gordon ramsay comes to a restaurant
and surprise surprise the restaurant
sucks you know i know but that's why i
also don't watch shows like that either
the exact same but there's like a
massive market yeah absolutely i agree
in some senses but then it also feels
like
like especially sky is just like so
inbred you know what i mean like it's
like they don't they don't take from
anything
but like else shows when i'm watching
them it just feels like the shows aren't
trying to take from anything interesting
they're all just taking from the
successful show in their own category
yeah right so i kind of feel like i'm
just losing my mind watching these shows
where like no one even tries to do
anything even remotely different it's
it's it's the issue of like anime that
is inspired by anime like isaika as a
genre is basically just like a
self-sucking like circle where it's it's
it's like the
is it uroboros where it's like [ __ ]
snake eating itself yeah yeah yeah
it is it isn't a robber and that's why
again like it it just feels derivative
like you you watch a show that is
supposedly brand new yeah and i just
read through the synopsis and i go i
feel like i've seen this show which is
which is i'm glad you say that sorry
yeah just because i feel like if i was
just saying that i feel like some people
might argue there's a language
difference going on where i can't fully
understand the nuance of these
characters like i just got like every
time i go to a bookstore right and i'm
trying to find something new and i go
over to the light novel section because
i always want to see like what's you
know what's possible
what's poppin right yeah because i'm
just curious it's like okay maybe
there's like a change or something right
i go over and i see all these new titles
i've never heard of and i just look at
the title and i look at the covers and i
go how is this title and cover any
different to the one next to it yeah
like it doesn't it just they just look
like spin-offs of each other
just from the feel and even going
through the synopsis i just think to
myself
it's like this
book right here was inspired by the book
sitting next to it and vice versa
there's no difference it's just a reskin
of the same thing so every time you know
i do like the the what will i be
watching which is where i you know i go
to the next season biggest lie of the
century exactly
but
nowadays the reason why i still continue
that show
on my channel is because it's not
because i actually sit through and watch
all the anime i talk about it's so that
i can hopefully find that one show yeah
that would actually be non-derivative
and somewhat interesting for me to
actually go and watch which which is why
for like the isekai genre now especially
like the show that i'm like been picking
up so much is mushoka tensei yeah which
is just like it's it's it's the isa kai
that basically started the whole easter
kind of novel trend in terms of this is
the one this is the one series that from
what i can see has like this is the one
progenitor for all the tropes or a lot
of the tropes that you've seen and like
watching the anime adaptation which is
airing right now it's just a really
[ __ ] good show it's like not it's i
i'm not saying it's a good show for an
easter guy it's just a really good show
it's it's a great [ __ ] fashion yeah
so and it's like and it's not until so
i've started watching mishka tennessee
i'm like halfway through the first
season because it's season two right now
right yeah season two yeah so i started
watching the first season just because
gone and a bunch of other people were
like oh this is the one that started all
and i was like bet i'll check it out
yeah and yeah i i completely agree like
it's it's not only you can see where all
of the origins of what made the isakai
genre so great came from but it's also
yeah as you said it's just a good show
yeah like like the fact that it just
like with so many sakai and so many of
these disposable anime nowadays it's
like the the first episode airs and the
anime is like you know how it is you
know how it is yeah we don't need to
explain [ __ ] we don't need to like build
up the world or the characters do you
know this character archetype you know
this world and like i watched i remember
watching the first episode of musho
katense and they spent like a whole
episode with where they're building up
this character and how he dies and how
he's a baby and how he like wakes up in
this world and he's just like figuring
out the world even though in every other
easter guy they're just like
dies isa guide it's like five minutes
yeah it really says it really says a lot
when i've watched some issac shut up
it really says a
a lot about isakai society
when i start up a show uh just a generic
yesikai show just wanting to see what it
is and
i think i'm watching episode one but it
feels like i'm halfway through the
season yeah just because they just
assume you already know all these tropes
yeah and it's like are we are you not
going to try and make it unique or
interesting or explain anything about
the world do you just assume that
everyone who watches the show already
has seen this show in some other form
because like sometimes you also watch an
anime as well where you can tell that
the people behind this put like put a
lot of effort into this there's there's
like that extra that extra tinge that
like extra sparkle that you know that
you know when an anime is just like
clearly thrown together like like like
form of mushog say for example like you
know with a lot of anime that they speak
where the characters speak a different
language and they just don't even bother
and they just like they they translate
it back into japanese even though the
characters are not technically speaking
japanese yeah so in michoacan say they
didn't just make up one language they
made up two
separate fantasy made-up languages for
this show which is used in the show and
i've never seen that with any other
anime especially not any other east
coast fancy anime yeah where the
characters are actually speaking to like
the fancy characters in their own
language which is just a made-up isakai
language or made-up fantasy language and
then different species of different
languages so they they literally have
just made up two separate languages i'm
just like this is this is the [ __ ] that
not like everyone will appreciate but
this is this is one big indicator that
someone
the people producing this show really
gives a [ __ ] yeah you know it's like
welsh or something yeah
it's like icelandic they made this [ __ ]
up it's just like
because you watched vineland saga right
yeah yeah so you remember that scene
where i i think i think it was like it
wasn't as glad but it was thorafin
talking to some french people with also
english people there and
is also is from uh scandinavian whatever
the scandinavian language is but they
were all speaking japanese
i really hate yeah and they were all
speaking japanese telling each other how
they can't understand what each other
was saying yeah even though they were
all speaking japanese and i'm just like
this is villain saga [ __ ] amazing
amazing anime but little things like
that are just like immersion breaking
you know it really does make a
difference and you know i that's what i
would argue some of the greatest fantasy
stories out there is what made it so i
mean like could you imagine if you were
watching [ __ ] lord of the rings and
yeah just alvin wasn't just spoken at
all and like every character speaking to
the elvens in english you know like that
could be such immersion breaking and it
would also just completely ruin the
world building even like netflix dramas
right they'll sometimes have like four
or five language different casts and
everything yeah yeah yeah yeah
and that's like something that i i
always get like i appreciate a [ __ ] ton
yeah yeah yeah
that i love that like yeah but in in
anime just feels like that that never
ever happens
i know it's happened a few times i
remember which ones i know it has but it
just never really happens like yeah
it just sucks as well though that i feel
the main reason why a lot of anime just
opt to not do that is just because they
think oh the audience isn't going to be
[ __ ] right i mean i i think most in in
an ideal world they would like to do it
but it's just
there's so much anime being made now
that are so much of it is made under
like a big time crowd
you know
i wonder what the whole anime thing is
is it like a natural thing
if me as an anime fan who's watched
anime for a very long time to get bored
of anime is it a natural occurrence or
is it or is it that i'm being picky i
don't know because
you know would you say you're you're
you're growing out of anime they're
definitely i don't think dare i say
really just a lot about society
it does say a lot about society one
thing that says a lot about society yeah
i feel like a lot of anime and you know
a lot of anime do this like this kind of
like disguise of like we're not for kids
but then you watch it and you watch the
character dialogue and how they talk and
you're like only a teenager would think
like this is how people talk to you yeah
yeah yeah like this is not this is not
like a real conversation that's what
like you know i hate to to use a western
example but like castlevania like the
script in castlevania was so goddamn
good yeah like the character
interactions in castlevania were so good
like i wanted to know more about these
characters every time they spoke even
the ones i didn't like i agree because
every single like every character when
they spoke about anything was a [ __ ]
delight but in anime it's always just
like it's got to serve the plot if it
doesn't turn about tits or
or funny i don't know like me being op
and like i saying earlier as well
another thing i really dislike right
lelouch is like anime's favorite
character and it really [ __ ] shows
because like there's so many characters
that are like lelouched light but like
failed to see what what made lelouch so
good right it's like diet lelouch
lelouch
is good to me because well mate what did
make lelouch good then one right first
of all you get you get lured in with
this oh my god he's a genius right he's
cool he's sick bro he's so strong and
then you realize he's a [ __ ]
psychopath and that he's he's scared as
well like anyone else in this world yeah
and the thing that i find that a lot of
and you know even like light right light
in death note like makes mistakes like
light worries light panics light freaks
out right like it with a lot of these
power fantasy shows where they try and
make a character that like resembles or
takes from that i find most of the time
it's so boring because there's
absolutely no other character trait to
them maybe the one thing they're sad
about is like the saitama thing where
like i'm so strong it's boring but even
then the way that one punch man does it
is really tasteful i don't know how they
i don't even know how to describe how
because the show doesn't take itself
saitama does it in a way that's kind of
like really fun and really playful that
doesn't really take itself too much but
any time i watch these power fantasy
shows i feel like my brain is rotting
like i'm watching it and i'm just like
this is
i'd rather watch big ed have like some
mental breakdown oh yeah
fiance like i don't know how to put it
like i feel like anime treats me like
i'm stupid and i hate that yeah a lot of
anime shows do you trust the audience
like they're stupid yeah i hate it maybe
because i love the math
jojo assumes i'm stupid and then he
doesn't give a [ __ ] and carries on
anyway yeah jojo doesn't care
you know it's [ __ ] stupid but i love
it
yeah i mean i was telling these boys
earlier that uh i've recently had to
start watching anime at like two times
speed at one point five times speed
which is like because like on top is so
boring which is like [ __ ] insane to
me and i don't watch it at that point
for enjoyment it's just because
someone's consuming yeah it's just for
like four like my seasonal videos where
i do have to watch everything i remember
it got to a point like two three years
ago where you look at the seasonal chart
and you're like if i watched everything
on this chart i'd literally be watching
two seasons worth of anime every week
yeah just to keep up with every show
being aired
i'm sorry yeah and it's just like it's
just impossible to actually consume or
watch everything coming out now that's
why a lot of it is just it's just
disposable [ __ ] honestly and i'll go no
i was about saying and you know that's i
guess like one of the biggest like
criticisms i get about like joey doesn't
watch anime it's like it's like yeah
because i can't it's there's so much
[ __ ] out there so much of it is so
derivative that i would dead ass rather
go back and watch shows that i didn't
get to watch all those years ago or
shows that came out before i was even
born right like i'd much rather spend
the time on that because there is
there is in fact less of a selection
all those years ago than there is every
single year like new shows coming out
right yeah and it's like yeah like i
don't know like i'm limited with my time
right like i don't want to spend
[ __ ] you know 20 hours of the day
watching a bunch of [ __ ] that i'm not
gonna remember next week because it's so
[ __ ] mediocre and redundant you
always do like these right so you do the
anime the seasonal anime videos yeah
right and like i i i watch them so you
know yeah watch them watch that watch
and like i feel like after i've watched
them now you'll always like talk about a
show or two that sounds amazing and i'll
never hear you ever mention ever again
what's up with that what's up with that
well uh i used to talk about shows that
have potential right okay and a few a
lot of them might not why not say pan
out and some of them do they might
fizzle out yeah they might fizzle out
that's why i do like my end of year
videos as well which is just like okay
these are the shows that i actually
stuck with because they're okay so there
are some good shows that are every
season but then there are some shows
that i feel are just the best and can
only on our best consumed via anime
right there are some shows that have
interesting concepts that i call like
manga recommendation shows uh which is
which is i watched like the first two
episodes i'm like this is really
interesting but like you know when it's
just like an average adaptation so what
happens is i just go off and read the
manga and i'm like cool i don't need to
watch the anime anymore i had a much
better experience reading them yeah yeah
yeah yeah what does happen yeah when you
just watch when you just watch a show
and you're just like i can get this
exact same experience just reading manga
and then you do and then you're like
great the seasonal anime did its job as
a manga recommendation channel
there's like something about
reading manga
that
is way more palatable for shitty shows
yeah i don't know why but there's i
think when these characters are so
boring because i can just speed run
through that boring ass dialogue it's
way more enjoyable well i think it's
because there are more
like places or more factors in anime
that leave for a larger room for arrow
yeah like because the only thing you
have to really worry about with a manga
is the dialogue and the artwork in the
story but whereas with anime you have
things like voice acting to worry about
you have things like sequencing to worry
about you have things like anime uh you
know animation and uh [ __ ] music and
like there's all these other factors
that could make that show
look and feel way more mediocre than the
core of the show yeah which is why like
i rarely read manga that hasn't been
released yet because i like i do feel
even now that i'm i'm reading more manga
that if there's a good anime adaptation
it's just like it's just untouched like
like a good anime adaptation of a good
manga [ __ ] untouched like i would
rather go i'd rather experience the
anime firsthand which is why when when
these anime do get released and i see
one or two episodes that's all i need to
see to be like okay this is going to be
a mediocre adaptation i'm just going to
read the manga you know and there's and
there's so many there's so many shows
right now which i feel like you can just
read the manga and you'll be completely
fine with it yeah but there are just
like those one or two gems every season
or like most seasons where you're just
like okay this th this is a banger i'm
glad anime exists because of these
[ __ ] shows yeah true like attack on
titan's one of those right oh yeah 100 i
love it
i cannot read the manga for a tag one
time yeah yeah i i refuse to read it
yeah as well
people can try and spoil it yeah i mean
no i mean like i know you know not to
marry anyone who does read the manga but
i just feel like attack on titan anime
is the best way to like experience that
story i agree i can't imagine getting
like the emotional highs i did with the
story without having watched it in the
anime first yeah
and again it's because i feel that
because of the added factors that make
an anime different from a manga like the
animation the voice acting the music
yeah in the case of the attack on titan
all of those were [ __ ] amazing so
it's just heightened about the animators
yeah yeah but it's just but that's the
thing it's like those like anime only
factors only heightened and already
great story characters so that's why i
feel you just get a better experience
with the anime yeah but a lot of anime
adaptations can't do that in fact they
pull it down sometimes yeah exactly
which is why like uh there's some shows
where like i know is gonna like slap
like chainsaw man yeah i'm like that's
one show where i'm like i could read the
monk because i know it's a [ __ ]
amazing manga yeah but i wanna i wanna
wait i wanna wait for the animation but
that's good though that you guys are
waiting because in case it sucks you
have a great market to look forward to
so it's just the win for you guys right
for me it's like i've already read the
manga multiple times now so like
i'm scared that my experience could go
really far down or it could just keep
getting better like i'm at a gambling
stage right now for you guys it's like i
don't care what the party is i'm [ __ ]
taking over the money
i i want to like anime i do
i want to what
i want to watch more man i really do and
i feel bad that i i feel like part of
the reason you don't watch more is
because
it's like harder for you to watch more
now living in japan right that too
because you have to go out there your
way because everything you watch is on
netflix now uh yeah i mean i i you know
i i a big thing for me with watching
stuff is like being comfortable like i
don't want to watch something at my
computer desk there like yeah
i do not want to do that yeah so i and i
like to chromecast things as we've we
all know yeah i like to broadcast things
um and i mean i can do with anime it's
just a lot more annoying to do it um you
know control doesn't work in japan and
you have to go through a lot of layers
and chromecast doesn't work with vpns
unless you have like yeah it's it's a
whole [ __ ] mess yeah yeah yeah but
there are obviously there's ways but um
it's a pain in the ass and netflix is a
very like hassle for three i don't have
to think you know everything just works
nicely i know that's so [ __ ] normal
of me i know that's normie but it works
yeah but like i have been slowly
starting to feel the same way like i
said you value your time yeah mild
frustration is like you know my house
could burn down and you know whatever
we'll deal with it that's a big problem
right i'll be devastated but there's
something about mild annoyances that get
to me on an emotional level way more
than like devastating are you saying
that your house burning down is a mild
inconvenience
you saved your house pointing down like
it was a mild annoyance bro
why why why did you why why does it
sound like your house burning down is
the same equivalent very good
insurance policy okay joey all right no
i mean like
something about like massive like really
big annoying things happen i don't know
why it's like easier for me to deal with
but like really annoying little things
that like you can't quite complain about
and it's not big enough to be a problem
exceptionally it's always annoying yeah
you know she's a little bit annoying you
know yeah that's why for me like the the
if you if there's one thing that will
get me frustrated every single [ __ ]
time without question it's just dealing
with small issues in tech yeah yeah like
i feel everything that annoys me more
than like i've never i'm not a very like
raging angry person but that is one
thing that will get me pissed off every
time yeah i think by the way by the way
if you haven't noticed the lighting is a
little bit different because uh our
wi-fi isn't working in this office right
now oh yeah and speaking of techies
you just reminded me and
like having to try and [ __ ] debug and
deal with the wi-fi issues in this
office which we haven't [ __ ] figured
out what the issue is yeah um has just
like put me in this like rage-inducing
yeah [ __ ] coma i swear to god that's
why they're like having a like so like
my pc set up at home is like quite
complicated there's a lot of stuff a lot
of moving things a lot of wires yeah i
have like two externally powered usb
ports that are all full i have like 15
plugs taken out like this [ __ ] isn't
like a fire hazard probably yeah yeah
but like
when one you're running the [ __ ]
white house
yeah
when one thing goes wrong it like [ __ ]
everything up right i have to deal with
so many tech issues for like streaming
or making youtube videos or anything
yeah i just don't want to deal with tech
issues when i when i want to relax like
that's not what i cause that it brings
me back into work it brings me back into
my engineering phase
where you turn on something you turn on
a device and uh something doesn't work
you write a piece of code and something
doesn't work it doesn't it doesn't
render out correctly and you're just
like
great uh so how do i figure out what's
going on uh and uh you just have to go
through everything one by one by one i
remember the worst
i remember because uh
since i've been trying to set up my new
office and do a like a proper streaming
setup and everything like that i'm just
like wow i can see why people complain
about cable management because before
before uh before when i moved to japan i
was just like one computer two monitors
speakers done don't care about streaming
don't care about that [ __ ] yeah now
we're like doing all sorts of different
things you got to worry about lighting
you're worried about all these different
plugs you've got to worry about you know
the go xlr or this like there's so many
different devices on our desk now and as
i was setting up i didn't i didn't i
overestimated how fast it would take to
like set everything up in a neat package
right like four days
so like i said like i set everything up
i'm just like okay let's let's like
cable manage this entire thing spent the
entire day trying to like cable manage
everything super neatly
setting up all my devices so that they
are like optimally placed set everything
up do it for an entire day and then i
forget that my desk is a standing desk
and i've been setting it up during the
sitting position and so what i did is i
set everything up i'm like great check
my emails stand up and then everything
and then the the screen just like turns
to black and everything falls down i'm
like oh god oh my god
yeah and i'm just like yeah
you know maybe uh maybe youtube was
overrated maybe stream is over people
talk about cable management too right
when you when you put it all in like one
braid like you put it all together when
you want to change one cable that [ __ ]
[ __ ] sucks you have to take
everything apart and then find the cable
like between like the nested all the
[ __ ] and then you're like all right
maybe being neat is just not worth it
maybe i should just be [ __ ] yeah my
idea of cable management in my place is
just take all of the wires and just get
them off the ground yeah that way
the roomba doesn't [ __ ] suck up the
wires it looks clean i can easily vacuum
under there i'm happy about that like i
streamed for like the first time in
months yesterday
for this for this jet stream and uh
pretty much
everything that could go wrong did go
wrong when i pressed the go live button
so i set up my stream setup right you
know set everything up tested everything
the day before because i know what it's
like i know how temperamental equipment
is so i tested everything before i went
to sleep everything was working fine um
i wake up and you know i didn't even
turn the computer off i put it into
sleep mode because i'm just like don't
[ __ ] up the settings
i i this like don't [ __ ] up the settings
this is the first time i'm going live in
my new office i know something's gonna
go wrong but i hope it doesn't go wrong
too badly yeah so i
go live you know i put on the starting
sign screens uh starting soon screen
everything's going well
i switch to my camera it's black and i'm
just like oh no oh [ __ ] no and i'm
just like okay turn turn the camera on
off because it's i so the camera we use
is a dslr with a cam link which is what
we used to trash data like it's just
saying that you connect a camera to a pc
race yeah yeah so i i
try restarting the camera in obs i try
turning the camera physically on and off
nothing nothing seems to be working and
i'm just like
[ __ ] i think i just need to restart the
computer and and so i restart i turn the
computer off restart the computer and
for some reason camp like the uh for
some reason the computer's not detecting
cam like it's not detecting the cable
yeah so i go under that this this keep
in mind this the [ __ ] chats just like
what the [ __ ] going on you know
it's the worst when it's happening with
the chat yeah chatting on your ass about
it
like look like logan stream you know
it's just like this this is this is
under like the time crunch of
i just went live people are already
waiting for me i've tweeted this [ __ ]
out yeah and so i
i go under the table and i look out i i
like
at this point i'm in panic mode so i
just take out all of my cable management
and everything everything like just
[ __ ] explodes i'm like there's
there's just like an explosion of wise
and i have to like it's trying to fight
like find out finding like one strand of
spaghetti in this in this [ __ ] sea of
wise to what this cam link wire is so i
find the camera
take it out plug it back in doesn't work
take it out plug it back into another
another slot it doesn't work and i'm
just like okay well i'm out of options
so i go into like i go into my storage
get out like my old logitech camera and
i'm like [ __ ] having to plug this into
a webcam yeah at this point 10 minutes
has passed i'm just like am i even going
to have any viewers i'm like whatever
plug it in webcam works thank god
go live again
and then obs has reset all of my
settings
so
so i i go live i go you see me on the
camera no noise and i'm just like and i
just
then i realized
and then i realized i can't just turn on
my mic anymore because my mic is plugged
through my go xlr which has about 10
different mic settings yeah on the
stream so like here i am just [ __ ]
i'm like you know you know when homer
simpson uh is at work going through a
nuclear like unique liberation he's just
like pressing buttons that was just me
just like am i okay guys can you hear me
can you hear me and like this is like
this is like the most stressful [ __ ]
which is i i empathize with any streamer
who goes through technical difficulties
because it there's nothing that kills an
energy of a stream not just for the
stream itself but for like your own
energy yeah quite like going through
technical difficulties when your stream
like crashes yeah and you like come back
you lose like half your viewers it's so
depressing yeah it's not that you care
about the numbers but it's just sad
seeing like you just gutted it in half
by just accidentally like [ __ ]
something out yeah yeah and [ __ ] cam
links are so temperamental it's like i
know that like it has to go in like a
certain usb port on my pc or it doesn't
work
that's weird yeah i haven't figured out
what i haven't even even figured out
what the issue i had is or why the
camera just stopped working for me it's
like it's so weird for me it's like if i
want to like record something through my
through cam link it's like i open obs
right yeah and then i turn the camera on
and usually it'll like pop up if it
works just doesn't pop up like 99 of the
time so i'm like what the [ __ ] turn it
off turn it on oh now it works yeah it's
weird
there's like a tech goblin it's just
being like did i work today maybe not
yeah every time you turn on cam link god
flips a coin sometimes it hands land's
tails and sometimes it lands the
settings are [ __ ] up oh time to [ __ ]
it up but yeah apparently even if i keep
the settings it still flips a coin
because uh yeah so i haven't debugged
the problem is yet and uh i just have to
like hope that god smells on me next
time i stream and uh nothing goes wrong
um yeah the thing that's annoying about
like that kind of problems and like tech
and streaming problems you can't even
like throw money at the problem to make
it go away yeah
you're like it's a problem you got to
learn how to fix it and it's pain in the
ass it's so annoying i've had like every
goddamn issue under the sun it's
terrible
something always breaks yeah of course
like like especially now that we've been
doing more live-action um live-action
content
um like just called a live-action
content like on camera i don't know
i love the live-action adaptation of
content
the live-action the live-action remake
of gigger
this is what happens when you watch too
much
like real life to me now it's just live
action that's like bro
i hung out with someone in live action
he's kind of nuts he goes outside and
looks like the grass is like whoa look
at the graphics
yeah
when i went outside i was like oh look
at this fps match yeah
why can't i go hundred and four four
hours
supermarkets just live action amazon
but it's like it's like made me realize
that
just making content isn't enough anymore
because you have to like just worrying
about making good content is enough
anymore because you have to worry about
so much tech things that i just never
thought about before because before it
was just me a mic and a script yeah now
she was very friendly with that right
yeah yeah i could barely plug in a
[ __ ] gpu two years ago now i have to
like learn how to like do all this like
tech [ __ ] and like deal with cam link
and like i'm thinking about getting a
second camera and i'm just like
terrified to even like think of the
possibilities of how much that's going
to [ __ ] up my already nice setup well
you can't use two cam links in one pc
yeah right so now i've got a few you can
you can though uh very
so
temperamental
though
like i'm like scared to do that now so
it's like [ __ ] what do i do
no because like yeah before it was like
before my entire youtube career was me a
script and an editing software right and
now it's just like me a concept maybe a
script and then lighting camera audio is
the light is the light flickering no
okay i got to change got to change the
iso settings no got to change the uh i'm
going to change the frame rate okay no
no is the audio no it's peaking why is
it peeking oh because the old because
the settings got changed and i'm just
like i just i just want to i just want
to make content actually i just want to
know why people have production
companies
they don't want to do it
because it's like impossible to focus on
what you're doing and you're worrying
about it
by the time all the tech gets gets
sorted you're just like i've wasted like
two hours and i haven't even done
anything yeah there's nothing i can
monetize because i haven't recorded i
haven't even started recording yet what
is this that's the one thing i think you
really gain from being like youtuber
twitch or any of that [ __ ] is that my my
god do you learn how to like [ __ ]
adapt fast oh yeah like you gotta you
gotta learn are you [ __ ]
your macgyver skills go through the
world yeah you have to yeah
if you're the kind of person who panics
and can't focus when shit's going wrong
then uh rip yeah yeah i i'd like to say
my engineering skills have like been
really useful in terms of just problem
solving because there's so many small
problem solving things you have to do
every time you're on a set or you're
doing something and you're making
content because
something inevitably goes wrong and
there is no manual or playbook about
what's going to go wrong but something
new is going to go wrong and you're
going to
figure out how to sort it out on the fly
do you think they'll ever be like uh i
remember seeing an article about this on
japanese twitter of japan was thinking
about like starting like university
courses for like youtubers and like uh
like online content creators i i think
maybe but i think there's definitely
room for like someone to be like hey i'm
a guy i will come to your house and set
everything up for you and and tell you
how to use it yeah yeah and you pay me a
lot of money but what if it's like we're
actually looking for that right now
if someone wants to help us set up our
twitch setup in a trash case office uh
we're trying to find a specialist we
actually can't like yeah we've had to
figure it out ourselves and we always
get comments about how junk our setup is
that's because we made it and we don't
know what the [ __ ] we're doing i think
it's it's it's like a decent setup for
live like it's not perfect but i think
we just want it to be like more
professional yes and it's like
impossible to find someone who's like
knowledgeable about this stuff yeah
exactly and normally if they are
knowledgeable about broadcasting they're
not they're not on twitch then they're
on uh you know they're on like an actual
tv yeah yeah yeah yeah like wouldn't it
be interesting if like you know you know
10 20 years down the road if youtube
just keeps you know going up and up and
up that i don't know maybe like our kids
will end up being like so uh what what
university degree are you gonna go into
science like i'm gonna go into youtube
and twitch i mean the way youtube's
evolving now is that the quality of
content
just keeps increasing you know it's
getting harder and harder to
compete with the larger creators because
the barrier of entry is just so much
higher now yeah like even talking about
you know an anime podcast yeah which is
what we started well we we put in like
thousands and thousands of dollars just
to get the best the basic setup in our
old studio and now we've like
we we have gone as professional as we
can be but that was like after having
like a surprise success with what we
were able to do but before that it was
like a lot of money that we invested and
we didn't know if it was going to turn
into anything we were in the red for a
while
thank god yeah so now i just think well
if you're a new content creator and
you're trying to you know it's like make
a podcast or complete compete with some
of the content
that uh is already established by a lot
of larger creators
you there's there's so much you have to
do there's so much have to worry about
um and it's getting harder and harder to
not only distinguish yourself but make
content which for the average viewer
they feel is like of a high enough
production level
because it's just about it's about like
doing what's in your means right yeah
yeah i've had i've had friends who are
like oh i want to do this thing and this
thing it's like yeah well that's good
but like you don't have the ability to
do that right now yeah so like scale it
down like you know mr beast was counting
to 100 000 because he could do that i'm
sure mr b said some grand visions of
giving away like 20 billion dollars or
something but you know you have to start
where well you can i think a lot of
people as well they they want to be on a
higher level but you just need to work
your way up especially if you're solo
right yeah yeah and and i would argue
that in the case with youtube it's not
always like tv or it's not that you know
just because you have tv quality is
going to make you successful because no
i feel there's still plenty of room
especially on youtube for you know quite
a quote less you know
lower quality content that is still just
as enjoyed as like
some of the most popular content on
youtube without a doubt is people just
screen recording minecraft yeah it's
like that exactly yeah it is it it it
speaks volumes about it's just a lot
about society um that
[Music]
you know just playing a game you know
yeah that's still like it's still gonna
be king and i think no matter how insane
it gets like people at the end of the
day are gonna wanna watch people [ __ ]
around and play in video games that's
like
that's because there's just something
fun about it i don't know i like it i
don't know yeah and like i i know people
are always like why do they always talk
about being youtubers and stuff and it's
like [ __ ] man it's almost no no no it's
only it's it's almost like it's our job
it's tough because like i also want to
talk about other things too but it's
it's like man like 99 of my day is me
doing
content creation it's like
what do you guys talk about when they go
to the pub they talk about their hard
day at the work the office right at work
this is exactly what we're doing
you guys have like [ __ ] you guys have
aneurysms when you try like to sort out
stream setups and stuff i do yeah
i do that this episode is sponsored by
boxing guys i've got a sudden craving
for d snacks
well joey look what's right in front of
you
is that a boxer uh what's a boxer i'm
glad you guys asked because i'm going to
tell you all about it right now box use
a monthly snapbox description service
that delivers original assortments of
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
a box who makes such a perfect and
memorable gift for anyone in your life
who appreciates japanese snacks and
culture especially during a time where
people aren't able to travel as easily
as they would like to and actually not
only would you be giving them a boxu but
also you would also be giving them the
chance to win free tickets to japan nani
did you just say free tickets to
jaypan's free tickets to japan because
boxing is having a giveaway where they
will be giving away five lucky winners
to win a free set of tickets anyone who
is subscribed before december 31st is
automatically entered link is in the
description down below so you can check
out the terms and conditions or other
methods of entry use our code trash
taste 10 and the link in the description
below to become eligible to win the
giveaway by subscribing to boxxu and the
code will get you 10 off your
subscription as well don't miss out on
this unique opportunity available for
anyone who subscribes until december
31st so what are you waiting for check
that link in the description for a
chance to win a free trip to japan come
to three horns come meet us oh
studio tour back to the show going back
to what you're talking about about how
you can't like how you're just bored of
the anime archetype or the anime
character archetype what's like the last
character you would say from like any
any medium that you were just like
yes
you know
i [ __ ] with him i'm not an architect i
[ __ ] with that squid kim joke
for real i was actually yeah every
character from squid game well every
character is
like flawed from squid game
yeah they're all pretty flawed yeah but
i would argue that's what made the show
so great that's because everyone sucked
yeah yeah yeah i
why i enjoyed about squid game compared
to like every other let's say death game
is a lot of other death games is that
yeah a lot of the death games just run
on complete archetypes yeah you know
like this person's the [ __ ] this
person's the good guy this person we did
have the [ __ ] in the good guy yeah we
we did we did but we're like but you
would have bare minimum right yeah but
the thing is at least i think why squid
game worked is that they gave more time
to develop that part of their
characteristics rather than them just
being the archetype right yeah i mean
there were entire episodes of squid game
that didn't have any like death game
[ __ ] involved at all it was just you
know the characters getting to know each
other you know knowing about the whole
like backstory of some of the characters
well like one of my favorite episodes of
squid game is when you know i don't know
if there's going to be spoilers but it's
like halfway through when you know they
all decide to quit squid game and they
all go back to society
literally second episode okay
spoilers for the second episode
it's when you know they all decide the
vote mass vote to quit and go back to
society and then they realize how much
they go back to it really says a lot
about society when they decide to go
back into the squid games like after how
much they realize that how much their
life [ __ ] sucks right like that
episode was great because you're not
only good to know about all the
characters and their backstories and
their relations to one another but it
also just like puts into a situation of
oh this world must really [ __ ] suck
to them that they have to resort to
going back right like that was great it
wasn't uh you know i it wasn't a perfect
show by any means definitely a lot of
things wrong with it and i understand
why it's so popular like it's very
engaging it's got a really good premise
and the characters like you they you
know you you hate someone which is
saying more than a lot of shows can get
right
a lot of characters you really feel i
felt strongly that i disliked and and a
lot of shows like anime i barely feel
[ __ ] anything about these [ __ ]
characters yeah but that's what i would
go down that's what i would argue is
that i think a character i think it
really
says a lot about society i can't [ __ ]
you need stuff
i know i like i like heard you
processing that in your mind because
you're just like i'm not going to say it
i'm not going to say i think you said it
really and then you're just like [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] i swear i'm not saying on
purpose i just i say that a lot i just
say that like you're like it really
abort abort what says a lot i bought a
border board a lot and i'm just like oh
it's too late
i say it so naturally my speech [ __ ]
this ruin has this meme has ruined me
and what the [ __ ] what was i even saying
i don't even know squid game i was
saying
boring yeah yeah yeah so i was gonna say
that uh i think a character that you end
up absolutely [ __ ] hating is a way
better character than a character you
feel nothing towards right 100 right and
and so many people think like oh this
character sucks because i hate him i'm
like well no that makes him a good
character because you feel something
towards that character yeah yeah right
it's it's like uh it's like uh game of
thrones and joffrey like i i found it so
interesting have you seen like
interviews of the actor josh so sorry
it's he's like he's like such a cool guy
and he's like one of the nicest guys
i've ever seen and
a a good actor makes a makes a hateable
character even more hateable yeah and
and i i felt really sorry for him uh
hearing stories about how you know kids
or you know people i say i say kids
watching game of thrones she's watching
surprise but like people actually
thought that he was his character and
people thought he was like an [ __ ]
and i'm just like what that blows my
mind how people can like actually look
at an actor and think yeah i bet
leonardo the character says the n-word
all the time bro and i saw him in django
he said it man that's like the same
that's like the same people who are like
wow i can't did you know that joji is
just as shitty of a person as filthy
frank it's like
that's like it's the same thing it's
like i can't believe he's like that in
real life you know it's definitely not a
character is discover filthy friend for
the first time
they're trying to [ __ ] cancel him
because like did you know five years ago
he was this filthy frank characters
making fun of
like mentally you know disabled people's
like yes
yes internet we didn't know thank you
amusing period to be honest yeah
how long ago was that because it felt
like yesterday i was like
it's about a year or two ago this is
very funny yeah because it's just
yeah you know times change and
definitely
definitely something like filthy thrank
and uh filthy thanks uh transition to
jojo till the thrank
i'm [ __ ] listening like crazy now
says a lot about society
i've completely forgotten my point
filthy frank
um
you just like i'm sorry darren brown's
my mind i'm sorry i [ __ ] [ __ ]
hacked my mind
i mean
it's just i don't know like that was it
now that i looked back at it it really
is an interesting period that filthy
frank was living in because for one my
god that [ __ ] would not fly and there's
a good reason why you quit but it is
strange how rapidly it changes yeah but
like i don't know i just i also remember
as well at the peak of uh of joji's
career as filthy frank how there were so
many kids that thought that that was
just him like yeah he was so good at
keeping up because yeah because so good
at just acting as the character and you
know any normal person who watched
filthy frank would know that of course
that was an over-exaggeration that was a
character but i remember at the time he
just joji just didn't exist you know i
remember i remember once he uh didn't he
like make a video about him coming out
as joji yeah he actually deleted that or
something yeah
yeah he made a yeah he made a vlog as
george miller who's you know his real
name yeah as like himself and how he
said that he absolutely hated his fan
base yeah like i guess the weird thing
is that is
tough to
talk about is that i guess when you're
when you're hired to play like joffrey
right right it's not it's not his it's
not the actor didn't make this character
the actor didn't make the story yeah i
used to think that's kind of difficult
to talk about with uh filthy frank is
that okay
he chose to make this character yeah
this is entirely his thing so it's like
how does that play an effect into
how much of the character do you excuse
right like i you know i i don't really
give a [ __ ] about it but it's
interesting seeing how other people talk
about it and how much they think you
know oh this is this is um this is
abhorrent you know this is him doing it
et cetera et cetera because he does have
control over the character right like he
makes the creative decisions so i do
wonder how much how much valid criticism
you can give in that from that position
right right well i mean i think it's the
same
criticism you'd give to any writer or
anyone who writes a script or a
character i mean you know why why not
just cancel george rr martin you know
why not cancel uh i guess yeah i guess
quentin tarantino you know for some of
the stuff he scripts and some of the
characters i i agree but it's just it's
it's one of those things it's called
quentin tarantino says the end woodless
it's weird because it's like we're in
the youtube era right yeah so it's i
feel like the rules have like kind of
changed why though they they shouldn't
yeah but i know i know i know why they i
i agree with you i think
than say someone like quentin texas
right i'm not saying i that's how i
think yeah but i think it's worth
discussing i i think a lot of the people
who try to cancel other people are you
know a younger generation and you know
it's it's going to take a learning
experience of when this younger
generation who are now in their teenage
years when they grow up
five ten years in the future and realize
some of the [ __ ] they're saying now are
being uh
like
are are things that can get them
cancelled
as the when they're an adult they
realize
oh okay maybe society just changes as
time goes on and what's socially
acceptable what's socially acceptable
changes and you know maybe we should
give some people the benefit of the
doubt sometimes when
things happen
i guarantee you know you go back 10
years ago to like any new grounds
comments right and you see the amount of
people throwing the r word and the f
word and the n word around and comments
like it means nothing because back then
on the internet
everyone it was just a general
understanding that yeah none of that
meant anything because it was the
internet now you look at it now and you
know if you if you wrote any kind of
comment or tweet like that it's insta
cancel yeah yeah yeah two points two
points two points first of all why why
is it that then these why do you think
that some people would then try and
cancel someone like filthy frank wright
who's a youtuber playing a character why
do you think they were trying to cancel
him but not say someone else who's just
like playing a character i think i think
it's because now the the younger
generation who don't know about filthy
frank right they only know george as
joji yeah who is this innocent guy who
just makes music right yeah
and you know it's to them filthy frank
is like his dark past you know it's it's
something
it really is
it's just it's just dark past that it's
like wow i can't believe i can't believe
he changed identities online to try and
hide the fact that some dark [ __ ] in the
past man has a [ __ ] villain backstory
here
it's like it's like his evil upbringing
right it's like that's that's how some
people perceive it though which just
made it so funny because i think to a
lot of these people who tried to cancel
jojo as filthy frank thought that he
changed his name to hide the filthy
frank yeah era when everyone knows
everyone who grew up with filthy frank
knows that no that's not the case he
just didn't want to keep making content
like that it didn't make him any money
because of the changing landscape of
youtube and he just wanted to focus on
music i'll save my other question for
later but next question then following
up on that question to you guys question
question to you guys right okay so
if we had
a filthy frank now yeah that came out
now do you think it would be any
different
yeah yeah totally because you think it
would never it would never be a thing no
because he
dude like but like i'm sure you've seen
enough filthy frank videos to know that
90 of the [ __ ] he made right would not
fly together right but like why is it
that
we we look back at that fondly and we
look back at these videos and then like
it's because we lived through it true
true true right and we know that it
wasn't serious we knew that it was a
caricature it was an over exaggeration i
always wonder as well i'm like okay so
you get to get to play a character right
and you get to do this stuff i wonder
though like how much are you allowed to
do as a said character like how how
where does it stop where you're like
okay this is too much
well it's it all depends on the time and
what's except for at the time i remember
i mean back when our parents growing up
it was cool to look up to rock stars who
trashed hotel rooms did [ __ ] drugs
until they you know they were more they
were more cocaine than blood you know
and uh and you know that was that was
what was cool at the time and that was
it was what was acceptable at the time
you know it's just imagined like it's
like a tick tock of someone being like i
worked at the hotel the who stayed at
and it was like really [ __ ] up they've
trashed their room and everything and
like you shouldn't support them
because i could just envision it it's
like the who is canceled for being rock
stars
you know honestly like we joke about
that but it might honestly be the case
what would happen because you don't hear
about like rock bands anymore doing [ __ ]
like that right because i feel they're
scared now that that the possibility of
that oh the the star of then is dead so
the repercussions just like they they at
the time they could get away with it
without repercussions yeah that was just
what was like accepted at the time i'm
not saying it's right but it was rock
and roll yeah it was it was rock and
roll yeah i mean yeah obviously i mean i
don't know how some of these [ __ ]
rock stars are still alive honestly
hearing something oh yeah stories
like yeah like keith richards is like he
should have died like 50 years ago from
the amount of coke he did
he's still playing with the rolling
stones it's like actually amazing like
he's actually like he's deo he's like
he's 100 percent
yeah i i i love talking about all that
stuff and like again considering it
because it's just so difficult to like
get anyone to like give you a good
definitive answer of where they think
things lie i think it's because it's so
yeah it is up to interpretation and i
think it it really does depend on the
person like there's probably a lot of
people watching this podcast who've
probably watched filthy thing i think
the shit's like cringe or like two years
right you know and and you know there's
some videos where i look back i'm like
oh okay yeah there were some videos
where i'm like okay that's a little too
far right but i i think i think part of
it is just acknowledging that you know
uh
society changes
and you know especially things that are
comedic yeah you know comedy a lot of
comedy pushes the edges pushes the edge
a lot of the times and what is
acceptable in that time period and just
because like there are there's [ __ ] i
found funny 10 years ago that is very
cringe or like very like
i don't know about background animation
yeah yeah exactly but like i acknowledge
that part of that is just because the
times were different and it's not it's
not that i was a bad person you know
it's not that we were bad kids or that
you know the type people there were you
know inherently bad it was just things
what what what is acceptable changes as
time goes on as different issues
different social issues get brought up
to the limelight and you're just like
okay well now that say this social issue
is brought up i do no longer find this
one thing funny and you know that's
that's part of how society evolves yeah
i mean you know i still fondly remember
when i was growing up with new grounds
and seeing so many new grounds
animations which at the time i thought
was like the funniest [ __ ] on the planet
like the first time i watched ultimate
showdown of ultimate destiny i thought
that was the funniest [ __ ] i've ever
seen in my life and i watch it now and
i'm like that's cute
it's like i can't laugh at it i can
reminisce about it but i can't like
throw my head back and laughter at it
anymore because it's just something that
yeah it's just as you said it's just
completely changed with not just how i
perceive comedy but just how
society can we stop saying society
it's in my mind it's such a power word
but like you know how the world
perceives comedy or like the the barrier
for comedy right and yeah yeah
another thing that i wanted to talk
about i wanted your opinion on is that
you were mentioning about you know how
you could say anything you wanted to say
in the comments and people
give a [ __ ]
in the uk did you see that they were
trying to get a law passed to like um
have it say that you need your like
public id to sign up to websites oh yeah
you could be like criminally charged if
you bully people online that was they
were trying to get that in the uk yeah
really that was actually a uh there was
a similar law like that in japan
actually years ago really um of uh
with 2chan
when 2chan was a thing um well i mean
when two chances started to become a
thing and it started to get really
serious is that there there were many
politicians that were like if you want
to use 2chan or any kind of message
board in japan you need to put like your
real identity and get like properly id
and scanners
yeah right exactly and uh i remember the
the founder of 2chan hiroyuki uh he went
on tv campaigning against it because he
was like that's just censoring like that
goes completely against the whole point
of sites like 2chan and just internet
stuff like that and he he basically i
mean he was ruthless about it he
basically said if you can't handle it
then [ __ ] off you know which you know in
some aspects yes i agree with but in
other aspects i do see like especially
nowadays with kids who
can get asked no sure whatsoever right
they they just think they can go ham on
everything without thinking of any
repercussions right yeah it's it's weird
man because uh you know obviously i i
can i can sympathize with people who
have had some really awful experiences
with public shaming and stuff like that
and it's really you know
i imagine it's not easy to deal with
yeah but on the other hand it's like all
right i get it
but come on anonymity is an amazing
thing and it empowers a lot of people
and you know it i feel like when you try
and take away anonymity from people it
disproportionately affects uh people who
are uh in worse positions you know um so
it's weird and also i thought okay so
let's say i have to make id to join
twitter in the uk braum james should
boot up that vpn yeah go to america like
i'm not signing up with my idea are you
kidding me even if even as a public
figure i do not want to give my id to
like twitter like yeah i do not want to
do that but that's the last thing right
it's like anonymity is such a powerful
no do you not give need to give it for
verification
do you oh what you do
[Laughter]
oh yeah
[Laughter]
connor i would never give up my id for
twitter i i would rather go to war jokes
but that tick mark though
put the verification that check mark
enticing i can't wait for this [ __ ]
kirby enthusiasm
poorly aced things
literally took like five seconds
i meant not like
that's just a general user i get what
you mean though
it's stupid yeah no but that's the thing
is like i was saying like i think that's
what's so powerful about anonymity is
that i think true anonymity is so
difficult to achieve outside of the
internet
that's what makes it so powerful on the
internet because it's really the only
place on the planet where you can really
just be completely anonymous okay and do
and say [ __ ] you know i mean i i hate
the fact that some people are just
really abhorrent to me online sometimes
for no particular reason but i'm not
gonna sit there and be like you know
people that means nobody gets to enjoy
the freedoms of the internet yeah yeah
and there's a lot of countries where
that's like life or death that anonymity
is very important like i would never
ever want to take that away and for a
blue check mark just just
just yeah just imagine i can just
imagine someone's like talking [ __ ] to
me right like quote retweeting saying
something mean and i'm like what's your
identity show me how old you are where
do you live let me contact the internet
police oh wait that's the thing now the
cyber police so what are you gonna do go
to prison because you [ __ ] ratioed
someone like like what's
how are you calling on my cyber lawyer
how are you going to define bullying
like that yeah this is the reason why
bullying laws have like never ever
worked because it's like how the [ __ ] do
you define bullying like one man's
insult is another men's like pepe left
like i don't know man it's like it's i
don't know you know what some people may
find funny and jovial other people may
find like [ __ ] deeply offensive yeah
yeah yeah but half the time if you're
super offended by something like that
it's probably on you yeah no i get like
the whole thing of like you know cyber
thing is like a a real thing and you
know it's not just a simple matter of oh
just just close your eyes or you know
just get off just don't look right yeah
just don't look at it right like you
know it's it's i obviously it's
obviously not that simple but you know
at the same time it's like yeah you know
people's thresholds of what they're
offended by is very different i mean i i
don't think there is a perfect solution
because yes i do think people would need
to like chill out online and i i don't
agree that the right solution to that is
by monitoring everyone and uh kind of
having to make it uh make it like a
default thing where you have to give up
your id and your you know your anonymity
and stuff like that yeah they already
have that [ __ ] anyway why do they need
it yeah they
already know that
the government doesn't [ __ ] already
know everything about it yeah right yeah
they're tracking you every day they know
what hentai i'm watching they don't
actually put cookies on my browser i'll
straight up tell them bro but leave me
alone i know yeah so i i guess i guess
my my philosophy behind it is just like
to keep your mans in check you know if
you do see if you do see someone acting
like a [ __ ] then you know it's it's
kind of a social thing though just say
oi stop being a [ __ ] stop being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
it's not hard
i need to piss quickly my shot even this
man needs to piss every two differently
half of the bottle one thing that pisses
me off about this debate right yeah is
that they always just piggyback off of
like really tragic events to push their
agenda of we need we need i don't know
we can't have anonymity yeah people are
dying out here from anonymity it's like
you're just you're just using like
really tragic events to push your agenda
how are people dying for a man
oh yeah you know like cyberbullying
people you know like uh oh
there's a very famous one with the
terrace house school oh yes oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah um but yeah i remember
that that whole started a debate as well
yeah yeah and then i know that
with the uh like english football
players people being like super racist
towards them it's really [ __ ] up and
then that's when the debate really
started going and it's like yeah this is
this is horrible but like the bigger
picture is like they're trying to like
take away
your that's amazing freedom like freedom
we already resigned so much why are you
just like giving it to them like take it
please please
and it's like you know
like people are still racist whether
they're anonymous or not right yeah it's
like
i think that i feel like we're not we're
not getting to the root of the problem
you know well go to the facebook groups
that's literally got their whole family
tree on there and they're saying the
worst [ __ ] they're going to change
anything it's like oh cool my uncle just
joined the kkk fan club on facebook it's
like great it's not anonymous it's still
racist you know
like that's the problem right it's like
i feel yeah as you said it's like
they're using the anonymous excuse to
cover up the actual root of the problem
right it's like the root of the problem
is not this anonymous person saying
racist [ __ ] it's the problem that that
person is a racist and sometimes i wish
one of us was just like [ __ ] weird as
[ __ ] so we could just like so you you
would just be like yeah dude i'm gonna
i'm like anti-vaxx 5g
just so that we'd have like more
interesting things more interesting
because i'm like why why are you going
to be [ __ ] sensible
why are you going to be so damn sensible
all the time
oh my god but i mean like like i guess i
guess this is like peeking back picking
back on like the discussion we had last
week about uh
about you know about hearing what the
other side has to say right and i can't
remember exactly what i said to like end
of the podcast um because that's that's
how it is on trash taste podcast but i
do remember
i do remember thinking one thing i
actually like doing is uh actually like
i like going to follow people from the
other side yeah we're like going we like
following people
from the other side just to see
what they're thinking or what their
argument is so one thing i actually like
doing is i like to see what some of like
say the craziest people are thinking
right just just so
not not because i want to believe them
just because i'm like
so curious about how they got to that
point right so one thing i like doing is
just listening to like flat earthers
defend defend what they believe defend
flat earth right you see that weird the
flat earth like online presences though
like there's so much like anti-semitism
there as well like weirdly yeah yeah
it's really bizarre i did i did see a
video of a guy i think i was a vice
dogmatry of a guy going to like a flat
earth convention maybe it's all gas no
breaks no it wasn't all gas no brakes it
was like a proper like documentary
going to a flat earth convention and it
was just yeah like i i couldn't even get
mad at the stuff they were talking about
because like anyone can anyone sensible
can tell you that what they're saying is
just doo doo coco but
but like at the same time i was so
fascinated being like i genuinely wonder
how you got to this point yeah like not
even to like hate just like i'm just
like as cure like psychologically i'm
just curious yeah exactly what you had
to input and what you had to be
surrounded by in order for you to truly
believe
that the earth is flat yeah and like
looking into it and seeing like so many
different like [ __ ] uh [ __ ] flat
earthers and different videos about flat
earthers i'm just like oh a lot of this
just comes down to like a core distrust
of the government and a system like a
systematic distrust it's it's so much of
a distrust that they would rather
believe that the earth is flat than
believe what scientists say and what's
like what an organization like nasa says
which is like it's it's it's it's
fascinating and it's also hilarious that
to them nasa is basically just like the
[ __ ] illuminati
the problem is that we've actually had
real conspiracies happen so so people
just have like this weird confidence
that like it's happened before we've
proven that these some conspiracy
theories have happened
and so they get like weirdly confident
about it i think in a sense from some
stuff like that i don't know i don't
have this mindset i like this is stuff
like that is so far from where i
have a view of things yeah i can't even
begin to like i can't i can't even begin
to like dive in no i can't i don't even
understand like how like and i think
this is the problem is that like
the like a lot of people just cannot
even remotely see where they're coming
from yeah yeah like with politics
sometimes you know you can kind of
understand right you just you disagree
but you can somewhat understand very
rarely yeah online but um you know but
with stuff like this it's so in like to
us it's so insane right yeah i don't
even know how to begin to be like yeah
you have a point i don't even know how
to how to entertain it i don't know i
don't know
to me it's just like it's not about
entertaining it's just like i'm just
genuinely curious i'm just like
genuinely like not even trying to change
your mind i'm just like genuinely
curious how the [ __ ] did you get to this
point for me it's not even
for me it's not even the point of like
me trying to figure out if i can even
say yeah you've got a point it's yeah
for me the mo all the time it's just go
on
i'm listening but i'm not going to like
taking anything yeah i am just listening
it's working my whole life growing up
right i've never met anyone who's been
into like really bizarre stuff like that
well not openly yeah no so it's kind of
like weird for me because i'm like okay
i've had my i've experienced my whole
life like i understand now as an adult i
can kind of have my own circles but we i
wonder why i was like growing up and
like university and stuff like that how
i've never really met anyone who's been
very hardcore into this at least in the
uk i don't know about elsewhere i think
it's maybe because they kind of come
down a dozen right like i feel it's like
they they make it i think media just
makes it so out that there is this like
massive large community that our flat
earth i think it's getting bigger i
think it is getting bigger
i still don't think it's to the point
where it's become noticeably bigger you
know like i still think at the end of
the day it is still very very tiny
population that actually is involved in
it it's it's hard it's hard to say right
it's hard at least at least it's to the
point where you know they're willing to
go to a convention about it i mean it
definitely feels like it's getting
bigger right like before before i
remember hearing about flat earthers and
i would just laugh like that was just
like an urban legend or something and
then you realize that people like this
actually exist
and uh
they they're getting they're getting
more of like a
they're getting larger because they have
a platform to be able to get larger on
which is you know the internet i mean i
guess the fact that an entire convention
exists about it exactly right this is
the thing that i i hate about it as well
is i hate talking about it because the
more you talk about it the more you like
give them a a strange sense of
confidence yeah because we're so sure
because we're so sure that we know that
the earth is round yeah yeah we know
that yeah
and it's weird the fact that we because
i feel like the fact that we almost keep
talking about it and being like yeah we
know we know it is you're dumb you're
dumb yeah they they think oh it's just
adding to the conspiracy because you're
you know it's it's what i've been told
that everyone's going to tell me i'm
stupid and that everyone's against me
yeah yeah and so it's this weird thing
where i'm like all right we just never
gave them any any kind of credence
before we never paid any attention to
them hundreds of years ago when they
said this or they think it was flat but
you know like not 1930s what i don't
know
give [ __ ] [ __ ] they were like yeah
whatever you're crazy have a nice day
yeah yeah i wouldn't talk about it right
but now because it's so well
discussed and so well uh spoke about i
feel like it almost lends itself more
confidence on more avenues people who
are susceptible to stuff like that to
get into it yeah yeah i feel the more we
talk about it the more it just gives the
that group of people power right
oh you finally recognized us yes we do
exist that's that's why i always come
from a place of i want to understand the
other side because like i feel like do
you understand i know i i do i do kind
of understand where they where do you
think it comes from where do you think
it comes from how does a person get to
like believing in something like that
well a lot of it like i said is such a a
distrust of the system that is this
yeah where does the distrust of the
system come from there's i mean there's
a lot of things that um that it could
come from a big thing is religion as
well you know a lot of a lot of flat
earthers you you see are you know very
very religious people not to say that
religion is the core cause of this you
know
i i have to [ __ ] preface that
i have to preface that as someone who is
religious myself
but you know it's it's it's people who
are
who
just who distrust like distrust the
government distrust organizations so
much that conspiracy theories to them
seem more palpitable
than what everyone else is telling them
because they've been they've grown up in
an environment where it's like don't
trust what everyone else is telling you
and because everyone around them is
telling them that they're wrong that
only like you said strengthens their
views and looks for more reasons for
them to like believe in the system right
believe believe and believe and
believe what they've come to believe i'm
sympathetic in some ways i feel like
even though yeah you're right like they
they don't trust in the systems almost
because i think in a lot of ways the
systems have failed them like systems
that uh you know we take for granted
because you know we had good upbringings
you know we were very lucky that we
had very
ordinary quote-unquote lives and yeah
had a good education i suppose and i
feel like if you if you are unfortunate
enough to just kind of
not have access to a lot of things and
you know you're told that certain
organizations or things will protect you
or you just learn from these things and
you don't and they let you down i can
understand why you'd almost
not trust these systems yeah yeah yeah
supposed to be put in place to help you
yeah um so yeah it's it's tough
which is why like i which is like i like
doing [ __ ] like this because especially
on the internet with how online
discourse is like i said like i said
last week a lot of people
people would know what they stand
against but very few people know what
they stand for and that's just because
it's so much easier to like prove
someone else wrong than prove yourself
right yeah right so it's it's come to a
point where
i i want to understand the other side
because one thing that's missing from a
lot of online discourse and online
discussions is people trying to [ __ ]
understand each other everyone's just
trying to prove each other wrong rather
than having a health having a healthy
debate and i think having an
understanding of the other side is the
first step to having a healthy debate
and so if i can understand flat earthers
then who the [ __ ] on the internet can't
i understand and that's why
and that's why i do this [ __ ] if open
conversations were normalized on the
internet we'd all be driving flying cars
you know like yeah yeah exactly yeah but
unfortunately we are still on the ground
yeah yeah
it's
it's
it says a lot about society and we can't
even have an open conversation about
flat earthers or not but like it's like
okay
people
very dumb and we're also extremely
susceptible right okay
like
any any like war ever right
you have to convince your people that
that that you want to fight something
yeah yeah how do you do that how do you
convince a whole population of people
i don't know ask hitler yeah right but
that's the thing right i believe this
was like really well documented after
world war ii is that like they what if
there's a very small but possible chance
that you have weapons of mass
destruction
do you like driving
i'll i'll find the video like mood and
ask me there was a there's a watch this
video and it was about this guy it's
basically talking about how well after
world war ii yeah a few um
uh jewish people who met fled and a few
scientists who lived in america yeah
they were they won the study how
people could go along with like really
bad atrocities in like world war ii
right like made your everyday guy like a
normal dude just kind of like sign up
and be like okay we'll we'll do this oh
yeah like the whole ant like the nazi
party yeah yeah how they just kind of
you know and some of the really horrible
stuff how you could convince people that
this was the right thing to do yeah
and it was basically explaining how like
there are like certain traits that one
might have which would make you more
susceptible
to to end up doing something like that
yeah some personality traits it was
really interesting because stuff that
you like you wouldn't think correlates
to you like you think oh i'm really
strong-willed yeah but maybe you like
strong leaders
strongly to ask you to do bad things oh
maybe he's justified it in no way that
makes sense right like it's i think i
think we all like to think that we are
like this this imp impel sort of word
impenetrable impenetrable fortress of
mind that nobody can affect our opinion
or uh
uh us to do something that we would
never do yeah i think in reality we're
it happens all the time mean i mean
there is there is literally an a
psychological experiment that uh details
i can't remember the exact name of the
experience podcast i remember this thing
yeah not exactly right
no no but i i i know actually can you
search up the experiment it's it's
a [ __ ]
it's the prisoner no it's not it's not
the prison that's that's the stanford
that's the stanford one um no the what
can you explain it so yeah they see
electricity one so it's the one where
authority it's where it's so they'll
basically they'll uh they'll tell them
that they're zapping you is it illness
is it milner's experiment i don't know
what experiments they'll turn up the
electricity because somebody tells them
to do it yeah because they say that it's
like a good but then they have like a
fake person screaming while they're
turning up the electricity yeah and
somebody keeps telling them to keep
doing it yeah and they keep doing it
because because a doctor or an authority
figure is telling them to keep doing it
so it's basically like fake squid game
right so you're you're put into a room
why don't you have to
this is probably like the deepest debate
we were ever having and god is like it's
kind of like a society we live in
you could have just said liar game you
know
it's better examples
because because actually okay ashley uh
i think it's called the milgram milgram
milgram's
basically the whole thing is framed as a
memory exercise right okay so
you the person who's being who's the uh
being experimented on basically uh
you're told that you're gonna take part
in a memory exercise and you're going to
sit in a room with a person next to you
and one of you is going to be the person
learning and one of you is going to be
the tester right
and so what you're told is that
if you are given an electric shock if
you get an answer wrong then in theory
then you should be a better learner
because you're you're doing like shock
therapies yourself that's what you're
told obviously that's complete [ __ ]
because this experiment's got nothing to
do with uh memory right so one of you by
chance
is
uh is the learner one of you
is the teacher or the experimenter
or the teacher but in reality you're
going to be given the teacher right
because you're the only person who's
actually being experimented on yeah
right and so the other person who is the
learner goes in another room
and
you have to uh you have to give them a
memory quiz right and the
the problem is they're going to get it
wrong and that's part of the design of
the experiment right and you're shown
you're you're given
you're given a taste of what the
electric shock that they're going to be
feeling feels like right and it's like
on the lowest level yeah right and so as
as this experiment goes on originally
they get the questions right and then
they get one answer wrong and so you
have to administer them an electric
shock yeah and they feel like pain right
and you hear them feel pain you don't
see it but you hear them in another room
even though it's just a pre-recording
yeah um and then as they get more
questions wrong
um the scientist tells you to up the
voltage and administer the shock right
and they keep getting it wrong right and
so the scientist keeps telling you to up
the voltage and keep administering this
electric shock until to a point where
like they are [ __ ] screaming out in
agony or you can hear them on the
speaker screaming out in agony and then
it gets to a point when it's just
silence right right and it's just
silence and then um the scientist keeps
telling you stop the voltage i'm
keep keep going keep going and like the
amount of people who even though you
know they were
totally uncomfortable with the fact that
they could hear someone screaming from
the fact that they were administering
administering this electric shock and it
still went silent they went all the way
up to the end and they still
administered like the most high voltage
in their mind electric shock
experiment because we trust authority
figures
and and like it just proved that
a lot of a lot of people more like you
know
the majority of people will be willing
to listen to a person who they view as a
as an authority figure yeah to tell them
to do something even if it's like a
battle even if it goes against what they
believe even if it's a horrible act and
it's it's uh it's a very interesting
psychological experiment
um i mean it could be turned into a
squid game that's why
this kind of sounds like a squid
thing it kind of sounds like a squid
game
this literally has nothing to do with
squid games squidward season two
milgram's experiment this has nothing to
do with squid games
i want to see milgram's experiment in
squid game season two game but it's like
actually a but they actually die yeah
no like see that's that's just goes to
show how
you know there's so many people who say
like i'm not gullible
but we all are to a certain degree
because we i feel we constantly get told
to do things that originally go against
what we believe in or you know are very
easily persuaded by just someone even if
they don't have that much of an
authoritative uh you know vibe about
them to just be like oh well i mean this
person who in my mind is more
authoritative about this particular
subject than i am so maybe i should just
trust them yeah like the whole fact that
you know we have a
literal audience of people who will
probably change their mind about
something we say on this show or
something we say on our own channels
you know seeing like an amazing they're
like yeah if so if i say so and so anime
sucks there's probably a number of
people who are like yeah you know what
he's probably right even though i have
zero authority over that person right
it's just scary because and and i know
that happens because it's hap it's the
opposite has happened to me as well
where i have all of ours yeah it happens
to all of us you know it's the reason
why we have conflict because people are
good at persuading people yeah it's it's
like
i feel i feel like we're just breaking
down the most fundamental problem about
humanity it's like you're not me we've
had like three deep conversations on
three episodes in a row now that's a
deep taste now this is like deep torture
deep taste
deep taste
i like
[Music]
is
like i never like i never like caught on
to this as a kid but remember when snake
gets a call from like a random person
you know yeah and at the time you know
you don't know who it is it's just
static on screen and then
he calls he he tells snake to call him
just call me deep throat and i'm just
like how did i never register that as a
kid
how was what was the context why was he
telling me to call him deep throat
because because he's like a deep voice
and that's the reason
i'm just as a kid playing i'm like
that's a cool name deep throat it's like
a dominatrix thing all over again it's
gonna be another like anyway hideo
kojima do you know what you're doing or
do you just like i is your mind just
building up
definitely planned that out for sure
it's like you probably went around to
everyone to come out he was like check
this out
maybe he was a mischievous i came up
with the best idea maybe it was a
mistranslation who knows i mean i mean
no
no if anything it's probably not even a
mistranslation it's probably a direct
translation because we don't call it
that in japanese so it's probably like
into a japanese audience it's like
like
that
hell yeah
sound like japanese harry potter bro
that is that is my favorite thing though
when uh they take like just ridiculous
english words and just like directly say
it in japanese yeah the japanese think
it's the coolest sounding thing ever
even though it sounds goofy as [ __ ]
japanese it's all just also just hideo
kojima you know oh yeah
that man's on one yeah he's on one oh no
haven't has any of you played uh death
standing again i really want to and then
i also really don't want to you know
what i mean because it's it's one of
those games where i just
i see so many clips out of context and
i'm just like i i want to i want to play
this just just to see this in context
this is the first trend like type games
i mean i just i just couldn't [ __ ]
believe that the final cut scene is too
early yeah you have to understand right
you i mean you know you guys know i
don't like cutscenes i can't i i
actually like i cannot play that game
i can just imagine you getting to that
final cut scene and
the moment you press the skip button you
miss about five percent of the game
can you even skip like i can i can just
imagine you starting the game and you're
just like where's the gameplay starting
yeah i would i would be the most walking
where's the gameplay
[Music]
enjoyed it the third time he played in
he's like good time
he's like the most monkey brain yeah
like uh
he he has more patience than me well i
mean i think it says a lot of that
donkey enjoyed a game like that
bad yeah i mean like yeah he agrees yeah
yeah
sure but like yeah i was saying like i
love like you know the whole thing about
like japanese just like directly
translating english names into japanese
and then the japanese thing it's cool
like harry potter characters are a
perfect example of that okay like
dumbledore right really cool english
name yeah dumbo dodo is not a cool man
i don't know the first ever every time i
hear a harry potter character said in a
japanese pronunciation yeah just like
why how is how did that
sound ten times goofier than the english
name i can't think of dumbledore now
without thinking about the meme of like
i can't either the dumbledore said
calmly oh yeah
has physically ruined those movies for
me i literally i i cannot watch the
goblet of fire like because all i will
be doing is waiting for that scene and
then i'll just and then the moment it
gets this thing you just turn it off
it's like i'm sad i'm done i'm done i'll
be like giggling away and someone'll be
like what's wrong i'm like nothing you
wouldn't you wouldn't understand you
wouldn't understand it
yeah
he said it's so calmly that's what
that's because you didn't know this is
meme where like in the books it's like
stephen fry's narrating it going and
dumbledore said calmly and then it cuts
to the movie like someone edited it and
then it's just dumbledore
it's just like it's so [ __ ] dumb did
you put your name into the goblet of
fire harry potter you put your name in a
couple of fires
please go and watch
it it's kind of like the equivalent of
uh of you know a trash tape a trash
taste viewer saying and then gant said
he prefers
bone on chicken caramel caramel
cut cut to the trash taste clip
yeah we've spoken a lot i was having a
discussion yesterday we're talking a lot
about good japanese food can we speak
about japanese food that [ __ ]
straight up sucks
be my guest first of all what do you
think sucks you go to the you go to the
user car right your boys are ordering
you're all like ordering right you're
getting gyoza gyoza is good you're
getting the the the uh maybe some
yakimiku right meat on a stick great
yeah
yeah sorry yeah i mean you can get some
nikki nikki too maybe i don't know
yeah um maybe maybe you get some fried
chicken with the balls
maybe maybe someone ordered something
and you're like oh this is this is fried
chicken right and you eat it you're like
why is it it tastes like bones oh it's
tendons it's like
cartilage like for some reason they're
just like deep fried cartilage and it's
like the worst eating experience oh i
love that i like it it's like imagine
greasy bones it's literally greasy bones
i love what it feels like it's like
you're crunching a small animal's bones
with oil like it's awful you gotta serve
dominance i agree with you corner
it's [ __ ] awful
gentlemen's agreement
that's a historical moment right there
ladies and gentlemen they agree on
something
it's so bad like i don't know how you
like it i used to hate it
if that's any what happened what
happened to you this is the man who
would eat he'll eat anything this is the
man who'll eat anything i understand
you'll eat anything but there has to be
some dishes where you're like i'll eat
it but like it's kind of whack right uh
olives
fermented fish [ __ ] uh chopped with uh
fermented soy beans i love it can't get
enough but joey's like
lips i i do not like old
why bro italians are crying right now
yeah i mean like i like olive oil i like
olive on pizza but like
why what part is it the is it the is it
the seed
i think it all it's just too strong of a
flavor you like olive oil yeah yeah i
mean you know what i mean
i don't like [ __ ] i don't down a pint
of olive oil
i am wearing a lot of like references to
an italian guy but no i'm not attacking
i just she's just sucking him out of
nowhere
he doesn't like olives any kind of
[ __ ] fermented [ __ ] but i i i draw
the line again
one green blonde
joey the man who tried like
who tried like bird fetus and i'm like i
kind of [ __ ] with it
a green animal get that [ __ ] out of here
i when i say i don't like olives it's
not that it's green or black both both
uh green mostly i don't yeah like black
olives i like actually
stronger
yeah green are a lot stronger and it's
like and when i say i don't like olives
it's not that if i get a plate of green
orange i'm not gonna eat it at all have
you seen that clip
sorry it's interesting i just have this
image of joey being that person where
it's just a clip of like uh a talk show
or something and the host goes bring out
the olives and like they bring out jar
of olives and this and this room just
starts [ __ ] loose no no no it's the
peaches right no it's
i don't know olives
saw another one of like this woman who
had like a deathly like uh like phobia
towards peaches oh i didn't see that one
and like it's like it's like an ellen
show yeah and they're like oh so you're
deathly afraid of peaches and then she
says like the scientific phobia word for
someone who's afraid of peaches and then
behind them on the giant screen is just
a picture of a peach and this woman just
screams out of the room
and the audience is laughing i'm like
this is horrible she literally just said
she doesn't like i got like
[Music]
[Music]
okay sorry finish your point future
point so
my point was when i say i don't like a
food
there is very rarely a food that i will
just straight up not eat like when i say
i don't like a food i mean like it
wouldn't be my first choice of eating it
right but if the if i'm at like you know
a house party or something like you know
wine and cheese party and i see some
olives there i'll [ __ ] eat it because
it comes with the thing right but if
someone just gave me some [ __ ] olives
and was like eat it now yeah and i'll be
like i don't know why this makes me so
angry no you say this right i mean it's
not my first choice it's like i i can
live the rest of my life not eating it
anymore i'd rather eat olives than most
izakaya food i think
i've
i think now that i've lived in japan for
a year i've kind of come to like not
really liking sakai food because like we
okay it's very limited we are crying
i remember when i first moved to japan i
thought i would never get [ __ ] bored
of this yeah and now two years in i'm
just like can i have a proper meal
please like
yeah it just kind of sucks because
sometimes you just want to like you want
to eat healthy but it's impossible to
eat oh yeah
i mean i think before before anyone
starts to think so i don't go to an easy
guy like ever no no no no like i'm also
like to the point now where i'm like i
could go an entire month without eating
izakaya yeah like easily you know it's
like we have yeah yeah but like every
now and then you know if i go to an
izakaya with some mates then yeah i'll
eat the food there because because this
is going to be the greatest meal of my
life because the issue is right let's
say you know british drinking culture
you know you have a meal and then you
have the drinks right yeah and i thought
what's cool about the izakaya is that
there is a whole eating culture around
it where you go to this he's a guy you
have a meal there and you can drink
shocker at the same time until i've
realized that most izakaya food is just
basically snacks so you're having a meal
basically just on like snacks or like
meat like it's it's not it's not like a
meal meal but it's still enough to fill
you up and you never i never go to an
izakaya and get like satisfied
satisfied with the meal you know it's
it's always just
it always feels like you just ate uh um
like a bag of like doritos or something
and that was like your meal for the day
that's kind of what it feels like you
don't come out of an izakaya you're
going i had a great meal you come out
full yeah yeah you come out you come up
four you come out feeling disgusting and
you come out like
i don't know yeah there's so many foods
to them they're just like this is bad
yeah like the
i don't know what fish it is but it's
just a toenail like it's literally a
toenail like it's oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah the uh the what is
it the
what what's the what they call the skate
fin skate fin is it i just called them
flat flaps what are they called
oh the stingrays they were all the rays
stingrays yeah not stingrays just raised
flap flaps
they're the ones that fly like this
they they they bring this out right it
looks like a toenail it looks shiva when
like [ __ ] rolling in his grave stevo
and died from a poisonous flat flap it's
like this it's like this [ __ ]
toenail-esque looking thing right and
it's like what does it drive it's dried
stingray or dried rice it comes out and
you have it and you're like it literally
tastes like nothing it doesn't taste of
anything what do you mean it tastes like
fish it actually doesn't even taste like
fish it tastes like nothing and it's
just chewy really hard and it's like why
why why they that's most like
dried fish snacks here that's just uh
someone same with like the shredded like
the shredded fish as well and like i
like the squishy squid stuff
um
the fried squid are like kind of like a
squid game five square there's like
because you can go to convening at like
20 different variations of squid squid
it tastes good i like squid it's good
but uh you know and then there's another
thing that's like i don't know what it
is it's like this it's like
uh uh
it's like octopus it's gooey it's got
like
oh takawasa yeah that stuff is old it's
like the it's it's octopus with wasabi
you just put it in a blender oh it's
rough oh it's raw yeah i love it oh it's
rough oh it's so rough and joey of
course the first time i came here made
me [ __ ] eat it
you know it's terrible and then like
half the great
[Music]
the thing is every japanese person will
order the order shiraku for you to like
try out but no one's going to tell you
what it is until you take your first
bite yeah i'm pretty sure that's what i
did with youtube right yeah exactly
that's [ __ ] hilarious this episode is
sponsored by manscaped ho ho ho
gentlemen the holidays came
early here at manscaped
that's wrong with us
landscape just launched new products
including their all-new ultra premium tm
body wash and two-in-one shampoo and
conditioner it's time to give yourself
or somebody who needs it god the gift of
beautiful skin hair and balls this
holiday season so go to manscape.com and
use this code trash taste for 20 off
plus free shipping jingle balls to the
walls fellas listen up untrim pubes are
a thing of the past and it's possible
you have santa's beard in your pants if
you know what i'm saying it's time to
leave your significant other some
cookies and milk at the bottom of your
chip
of course i am talking about the
manscape tm performance package 4.0 look
at this beauty oh
damn inside the performance packs 4.0
you'll find the signature lawnmower tm
4.0 this electric trimmer has propriety
advanced skin safe tm technology to
reduce cuts to your nuts it's also
waterproof so you can use it in the
shower it's a great gift for your
partner with less mess so get twenty
percent off and free shipping with the
code trashtaste at manscape.com that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code trashtest
clean up your nuts and make santa proud
this year thank you demandscape for
sponsoring us this episode back to the
video i hope santa uses manscape
i prefer anything other than that sperm
sack it's not that it's a sperm sack
it's that it tastes like [ __ ] if spum
sucks tasted good i'll chow down on one
i don't know i i got no i got no resume
he's a joke he's a jojo fan
he's practically my my job man
you know
but like okay and the thing the thing
with shirako though is like it's the
same thing with me it's like i like it
which fish is it from by the way
i couldn't tell you want one of them but
like who did this there's some foods i'm
like who
who the japanese like you opened this
fish up sure like the the reproductive
organ was like bruh you're gonna eat
this yeah but japan is a country that's
like oh this this fish is poisonous that
and then they spend the next 100 years
training to eat the tiny little pot that
tastes like nothing do you like sea
urchin
yes i don't like chia chin right you
don't and then i i don't it's really
strong flavor to me
is like one of the most like it's not
true it's very very very strong is one
of the most like polarizing sushi i
think it's like the wasabi of fish it's
like it like it feels like a a gas
attack went off in your mouth what are
you talking about for me yeah it's it's
literally called the butter of the sea
it's smooth as [ __ ] what do you what are
you what it's so strong what are you
actually talking about i don't think you
wait
i have i
i was like why is it a paste that's
weird until i went to a place where they
like cracked that bad boy open in front
of me and scooped it out
and i was like
i'm not watering right now connor i
could only get so erect come on i had
again i had reservations against it i'd
had chin before i wasn't a fan you know
it's a cool name yeah one of the coolest
fishes names out there in english yeah
sea urchin
it sounds like some norse god like you
know what i mean it's like oh it's like
salmon i sleep bro sea urchin yeah it's
like something died to make this fish
right
so they crack it open and you know again
like with wasabi i don't typically like
wasabi it like like the the
kind of it's the horseradish it's
horrifying wasabi i'm not a big fan of
it but then you know i when i went to a
place and they gave real wasabi i was
like okay i'll give it a chance yeah it
was insanely different amazing yeah
actually amazing if you don't like
wasabi try the real stuff it's insanely
expensive but if you get a chance i
don't know how it just came up you're
you're not gonna get the chance no it's
it's i don't know how it it's
just in a course and they just brought
it out and they would like you grind it
i'm like i don't know what it is it's
very expensive he's like asked me to
grind a diamond so
i i you know they crack it open they put
it on i'm like okay i try it it tastes
like [ __ ] still i couldn't i couldn't
enjoy it and i wanted to like it so
badly what what is it what is it that
you don't like about it because i've
cause i've i've given sea urchin to a
bunch of friends who've come here
because i'm like whenever i whenever
friends come over and they want to they
say i want to go eat something real
sushi quote unquote yeah i'm like all
right but you have to be open to trying
some [ __ ] that you're not going to get
oh please yeah thank you yeah you have
your children
yes yes
i'm like yeah i'm like okay i'll take
you to a social place but you have to be
open to not just trying a [ __ ]
california role like you have to try
like some weird [ __ ] so are you prepared
for that and i always give him sea
urchin and it's like so far i think in
my with my group of friends it's been a
50 50. half of them love it and the
other half say that it's like too fishy
i think the problem with sea urchin is
that it's really easy to get bad quality
yeah you need notoriously like one of
the fish that can make you like sick
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like like i i've i've had bad sea urchin
before and it it tastes bad you know but
like if it's like really good quality
sea urchin like the freshest [ __ ] it's
like oyster like bad oyster is really
bad but good oyster is like yeah what i
love about okay okay
what i love about sea urchin is that it
literally i don't know how i can
describe it but it literally feels like
you are eating the sea that's just
that's kind of what it feels like to me
right no no
no no i agree all of it no because it's
like it's it's fishy but it also has
like a salty texture yeah yeah it's a
little bit sweet it's a little bit sweet
it's like really good
[Music]
it's kind of like
like downing some sea water but it
tastes actually nice it's really good
i've never heard somebody
concentrating
it's like if you could take the essence
of the sea and put it into a food that
would be sea urchin
millions of real ones
a real one mainly interesting
very international basis
you know when i go to like a sushi
restaurant where the the sushi chef what
is did you call a sushi chef do you is
it a sushi chef yeah it's just your
favorite did you master masturbate
she just goes to masters you know when
you go to restaurants where because you
know you can go to the the conveyor ones
which are good too really cheap really
easy really nice or you can go to ones
where it's like a course yeah you sit in
front of it and at lunch menu it's only
pretty cheap in japan pretty good and
when i've gone there
always when sea urchin comes up i do the
okay first of all i never ever waste the
sushi especially if the guy's right
there i wouldn't dare be like no i'm
okay yeah
i feel like that is like a sin like you
cannot look this i mean uh he was i mean
20 years i think i'd rather like slap
his wife in the face
like refuse
yeah so like the sea urchin comes out
and and the thing is sometimes if it's a
really small restaurant they watch you
they watch you eat it because they want
to hear you say like oh it's amazing
that's good yeah i don't mind because
most of the time [ __ ] slaps and i'm like
oh there's another one this is a good
one keep it coming don't miss it
oh that mackerel oh and he's like bring
out the next one i'm ready
all right well
i'll get the water ready get the green
tea ready i just like put it all in one
and i'm like
oyshee
[Music]
wait but don't because most places like
that they tell you beforehand what fish
you like and what fish you don't like
right
shit's going so fast i don't even know
what they're saying half the time oh
okay so so so life hack for people
coming to japan i don't even know what's
the sea urchin name in japanese africa
uni that's it
so so most places that aren't convey
about sushi and it's like a set course
the shuffle usually if it's a good
restaurant they'll come out and tell you
what fish do you not like yeah because
they're not going to [ __ ] waste it on
someone who doesn't like that [ __ ] i'm
wasting this man's ingredients so next
time just say like no uni and they'll be
like
i want to show full appreciation to this
guy in his craft
but you can by telling them that like
i'm not going to eat this there is no
bigger compliment than me being like
boss man the rest of this food was
banging i'm you know you i don't have
faith if i was a chef i'd rather you
just straight up tell me yeah what fish
you don't want
i don't know man
sitting there and watching you go
i don't no no no i wouldn't dare pull a
face bro it's it's a face it's it's mild
discomfort before the moment i put in my
mouth the stone cold face
[Music]
i kind of had that with a shirako as
well yeah you got it like as a british
person it is not
i was in this i was in this restaurant
and we uh we missed the fact that
shidaka was part of the course because
it was like it was like this um it was
like this like seven course meal
um in the sperm sack right yeah yeah it
was a sperm cycle and um
this hotel we were staying at we missed
about there was shiraka there and
they put it in front of us uh to in uh
like with me and sydney right yeah and i
was just like oh
oh no it's this thing right and cindy
doesn't know what it is and i'm just
like i'm just like let her read it i'm
just like do i tell her or do i not and
uh
and uh i i i unfortunately i'm i'm i'm a
i'm a loving partner i did tell her no
because right she's not gonna eat it
she's not gonna eat it yeah i i thought
she was like me right i thought she'd be
like you know what i'll still eat it
because it's japanese culture i wanna i
wanna you know i want to
show respect right and she's like i'm
not [ __ ] in it
so this is this this is after me
psyching myself up right and and i'm
just like okay
i can deep throat this i'm i'm a deep
throat this [ __ ] sperm sac right now
my favorite metal gear
metal gear solid music is playing in
this man's ear
the guy just turns to sydney goes and
call me
so i'm just like oh
i take it i like
swallow in one
isn't it like a string like isn't it
like a bunch it's like a bunch right so
so well it's like it's like swallowing a
fallopian tube yeah yeah
it's done
sydney all right you do yours and she's
like have it i'm like sydney eat it i'm
like i'm not gonna [ __ ] eat it i'm
like you want to tell the people i'm not
gonna eat it i'm like i'm not telling
people we're we're gonna finish our
[ __ ] food we're not gonna show
disrespect and she was like do it you
can do it i'm just like
no
i'm not going to do it and it was just
like a [ __ ] game of chicken
do it
eat eat the sperm
can't you eat it and in the end i'm just
like fine i'll [ __ ] do it
and on that day i deep throated two fish
sperm sacks
and i never want to do it again because
you know what that [ __ ] did not feel
that [ __ ] did not sit right in my
stomach man but okay here's the question
though are you the type of person who
gets conceptually grossed out by food no
i i don't
just off the premise alone i i won't
ever have like a yes or no answer to
each other right so if you if i never
told you ever that [ __ ] ako was sperm
it's slimy it's too slimy
it's too creamy it has this really weird
aftertaste that that that is
creamy huh it's creamy yeah it was great
it was really creamy that's very shirako
surprisingly he is really really [ __ ]
creamy it's creamy it's viscous
okay yes yes yes you know what the taste
and the texture of shiracho is exactly
what you think it is yeah what can i say
it's creamy it's slimy it's viscous what
[ __ ] was just a fancy name it's fish nut
yeah i i can the thing that i have just
realized my weakness is slime like
anything that is slimy i really struggle
you're not the first person though right
right
and i don't know like
clearly i just haven't been raised to
eat slimy things like i never had slimy
things in my life yeah i wish i did
because i feel like i've been deeper but
that's the thing like that's why i don't
blame anyone who doesn't like things
like okra or not or [ __ ] or anything
like that because if you didn't grow up
with that [ __ ] it's like eating so to me
it is like too close to the consistency
of snot yeah yeah and like when you go
to a real man
you get it you deep throat
so when you go to a real can right you
get a meal like a set meal in japan
right you get a lot of food and it's
always like so i'm gonna i'm gonna just
call it like levels no not courses it's
like level one through three right it's
always the most painful
because they just it's always cold and
it's always slimy food that comes from
first i don't know why they've done this
it's like they're trying to like not all
of it are slimy okay some of it's slimy
yeah i've been to some places where they
were like they were like for some reason
some guy woke up and was like every meal
must have slime like i went to one
ryokan and i was like every meal i was
like i can't wait for the next one i
wonder what it will be turns out more
slime stuff and i'm like come on i can't
get a win man
but like always there's at least like
you get like you get like four little
dishes two of them will be cold jelly or
slimy guaranteed i don't know why i
don't know why they're obsessed with
putting slimy stuff japan is weirdly
japan is weirdly obsessed with jelly
they're like a nickelodeon kid bro it's
like you they have more slime than them
like i don't understand
japanese are the only ones who watch
nickelodeon guts went and looks
delicious yeah
they're like they're like seeing this
nickelodeon slime being pulled out like
[ __ ] they're wasting so much food
eat it
yeah i don't know it's like we do have
like very traditional japanese foods are
either slimy or gelatinous it's a shame
because i really want to i really want
to give it a good go and i eat it most
of the time but with much pain with
great difficulty and again it's i feel
that i i absolutely do not blame anyone
who doesn't like that side of japanese
cuisine because it is a tall hurdle
especially if you weren't raised on it
right right yeah i like i i feel i i can
confidently say that i would not like
natto or okra or you know anything
gelatinous or anything like that if i
didn't grow up with it yeah just because
yeah the first time you put it in your
mouth it's like this shouldn't be in my
mouth
this should be up someone's nose
you know it's and it's like it is like
discomforting it's weird because it's
like something
i'm like no something grilled okay yeah
okay
yeah exactly right i mean i like cold
things it's just
slimy things you know that's just but
and normally things i don't like or
what's worse a hot slimy thing or a cold
slime you think
can you get a honey i guess you can get
a hot slimey thing what's the hot slime
you think
what is a hot slimey thing dish i don't
you put natto in a microwave
that just like accentuates the [ __ ]
smell that sounds horrible oh my god can
you imagine microwaving natto you do
isn't it like dude
packs right yeah because it comes frozen
so you have to microwave it right you
better like been done
someone bought frozen natto
disgusting yeah that's why i put it in a
microwave mainly
angry
if she wants to interrupt she'll hold a
sign that says incest but microwave
natto that's where she draws
that's the thing is that yeah it sucks
most of these like gelatinous or slimy
dishes are so goddamn healthy yeah yeah
and they have so much good stuff here
i'm like damn i wish i could
how do you feel about insects then
i think if i say incest god's like god
question you connor how do you feel
about incest speaking of slimy things
insects i you know that water bug smelt
vile
you know that's because it was violent i
have no qualms about eating it i'll try
it but you didn't try it yeah you didn't
try i did if i had to i'll try it i'm
not gonna like it but i'll try it but
when god had to do the forefoot and i
was like let me try you didn't try it
you're like i'm like i'm not going to i
don't mean to you literally just said if
given the opportunity i will try it if i
was in a spot where you're like on this
course is uh a locust a sandwich of
locust i'm like all right all right i'll
give it a shot
okay but
if it's if it's what's there between
that and
you someone next to you having a water
bargain yeah it might be pressure it
might be the only time social social
pressure what do you mean
the reason why most people make most
mistakes in their lives so so basically
it's the british and you who is
incapable of saying no 100 and in front
of someone
and you'd rather just do it
even though you're like uncomfortable
yeah no god no i'd rather eat my own
toenail than be up here socially awkward
for more than four minutes you know what
i mean like
it's not not a question in my mind
[Music]
you know i there's something about table
manners that i think that is is i don't
know it's very british isn't it i don't
know it is very british there's
something about not being rude at the
table especially is like very like like
big in my mind that i'm like you cannot
be rude at a table is that a british
thing or is that just like a sensible
thing
i don't know because in my head like i'm
not british but i have the exact same
thought of like don't be rude at the
dinner table but like doing things like
correctly as well like i don't know
whenever i meet like friends parents or
stuff i'll always make like quadruple
sure i'm like polite oh yeah but oh yeah
i like that doesn't matter what they put
on my plate if i'm dying i will eat it
just you know but uh i don't i don't
think it's a pretty i think this is
common sense well
i mean okay
it's more like okay say say you're at a
restaurant yeah and the waiter is rude
or the waiter
makes the wrong order yeah or the way to
you know or something happens in that
restaurant experience that is unpleasant
do you say something to the waiter do
you call management no ah it really
depends how bad that is my least
favorite thing is making a scene at a
restaurant yeah that is the one thing
you will never catch me you know there's
nothing will make me dislike a person
more that if they're like have a
complaint that i feel is like completely
unvalid and they're getting the waiter
over to like yeah do something like like
if you're getting the waiter over you
like someone bet someone a bit of like
[ __ ] on your [ __ ] dish you know yeah
that better be something yeah i mean
yeah i have like a limit like if there's
more flies in my soup than soup then
yeah obviously
but you get a you get a meal yeah
there's a hair in your food yeah what do
you do just take the hair out yeah
that's what i do yeah same man you just
you know and because in my head i'm like
okay i'll call the waiter right i'll say
to the way that there's a hair in my
soup the [ __ ] the waiter gonna do
about it yeah you know in some people
like oh my bad let me get it for you as
much as i as much as i want to be like
okay yeah i mean i wouldn't lie it makes
me slightly uncomfortable eating the
thing yeah yeah and that's part of the
dining experience but i mean i mean that
is that once you find a hair in your
soup that's that's it there's no going
back there's no saving the fact that
there is hair in your suit calling the
waiter isn't going to make the situation
better all right another scenario right
you're at the dinner table two of you
have hair in your food yeah now what
both of you to pull it out or that that
i feel like that ups the anteater then
i'll just then i'll just look being like
oh my hair's a little bit longer and
just make like a joke out of it also it
depends on like the restaurant right
sometimes sometimes you're you sometimes
you have these kind of mcdonald's bro
i'm just playing another
sometimes you're at a restaurant and the
restaurant's busy as [ __ ] and you're
just like and you're just like well this
doesn't excuse it but it seems it's
gonna be more effort to call someone
over and complain about it then just try
and enjoy this if it's like an empty
restaurant and i'm the only one in there
and there was a hair in my soup or
whatever like something horrible
happened then maybe i might call the
waiter because i know that the waiter is
more free yeah but if it's a packed
restaurant i'm not gonna be like oh yeah
stop everything you're doing i have a
hair in my suit yeah i'm not going to do
it like there's sometimes right yeah you
know a pretty common mistake uh the way
to get your order wrong yeah now you
know now
do you say that you they got your order
wrong or do you just eat the food and
just you know be sad that you they got
your order wrong now now it depends half
no it depends if you waited 15 20
minutes for the food you're like excuse
me i got the wrong food unfortunately if
you like at some of these restaurants
where you're like there for half an hour
to 45 minutes you're just like i am not
waiting another [ __ ] half an hour i'm
just gonna eat this food and leave a bad
review and just be done with it there's
some there's like again that heavily
depends on me it's like okay
how different is this to what i ordered
like if we're talking i ordered the like
fifty dollar steak and they bring out a
ten dollar appetizer yeah yeah like
that's your meal
okay hold up hold up yeah but if it's
like a fifty dollar steak versus like a
forty five dollar burger then i'll be
like you know what maybe i was in the
mood for a book it's not inherently
value it's more like do i feel like
proportionally i'm getting something
that i would also enjoy and it's also of
the same capacity yeah yeah yeah you
know if if i order the steak or a burger
and you bring out the day of this the
soup of the day or whatever i'm like
these
because also another thing is that if
are you with a group of friends as well
because you know sometimes it happens
sometimes someone gets the order wrong
right and you have to like wait for that
guy to also get his order and then
finish his food and then like at that
point you're not enjoying the meal
because everyone's sitting there staring
you to [ __ ] finish your meal because
everyone's already finished and i'm just
like that's yeah it's true that's it
it's uh
that these are all the things to
consider whether just just read the room
and you'll know if it's like right to
call the waiter or not and then the
british the british way is 99 out of
like 199 out of 100 times you don't call
the waiter you just like you just sit
down and deal with it yeah and then uh
you set the uh restaurant on fire
afterwards yeah easy just don't go back
to that restaurant
that's when you were you were like
single right when you if you could go on
a date would you eat stuff like wings in
front of your day
like stuff that gets like a little messy
yeah you would like no no no no fox
given no
do i seem like you got a naughty wings
in front of me no you seem like you you
i would you would eat wings
off the ground in front of me like
totally oblivious to the fact that she's
like bro he looks like a toddler
like joey's just like do you like me
joe's like bibbed up like [ __ ] source
all over and joey's like so what do you
do for a job
when he like a [ __ ] alignment chart
like trash
members of trash taste who would who
would eat wings in front of that date
i'm like on the far end of the spectrum
being like yes i would absolutely
like i don't give a [ __ ] who you are if
i'm in the mood for wings bro i'm eating
[ __ ] wings
orders were like connor orders wings and
doesn't eat it
so i'm just gonna enjoy the smell
at best i would get a tissue and hold
the end of it and very like like like a
hamster almost just trying to like get
the meat off without making like lip
contact
no for me i'll give it a go
breaks out the knife and fork to eat
wings i would try and do that too
but then i would get frustrated and i'd
be like tissue time we'll get a tissue
on the sauce on the end at lunchtime
meanwhile the most common courtesy i'll
give to my date is i'll give them a word
of warning beforehand being like can i
start eating these wings all right
cheers oh i feel like i've definitely
had an experience where i've been i've
been eating something with a knife and
fork and that i've had like a mental
breakdown i'm like listen i can't do
this i'm just gonna get it with my hand
you okay with that it might get a little
messy right now i'm doing it and doing
it [ __ ] you i mean i'm fine eating my
wings with a knife and fork i actually
prefer to eat a lot of
wings how can you get in there and get
all the [ __ ] off that is like chaos i
have like i have i've perfected the
technique right what is some anime
[ __ ] power move what is this i've i
mean i've been eating wings all my life
and sometimes sometimes you know i you
know sometimes
i just don't like getting my hands dirty
sometimes you know you know something
especially with like wings that have a
lot of sauce on it right yeah yeah you
have you have some wings with a lot of
sauce in it you don't get that smell off
your fingers even if you like wash it
off i love it it's like it like it like
just it feels sticky if you go to the
toilet you wash your hands with soap you
all have that like
feeling
it reminds me of a good time
when i get a little bit of sauce on my
face i'm like all right now the shackles
are off there's no holding back i'm
going all in i'm not holding back i
don't care how much mess gets on my face
anymore look man like
i say if the girl gets put off by the
fact that you got some [ __ ] wing
sauce on your face she wasn't right for
you to begin with it's true it's true if
you're a jojo fan if the guy gets put
off the best the best goal will be like
i still like him even though he eats
like a [ __ ] animal
just saying
find around this right for you gentlemen
weird is it i i so what i'm eating
obviously i was always told it was rude
to put your elbows on the table was that
something you were told yes
isn't it
that's what that's what i was talking
about i wasn't told that i got gone
maybe that was and i just didn't like if
you if you're eating you know like
this yeah that's rude oh i mean i've
just never done that so yeah
i was born civilized
i was told in japan that it's so i would
always like what i do is normally if i'm
eating with like a fork or something i
just like keep my hand on my like lap or
something yeah yes in japanese you have
to put your hand on yeah i was told it
in japan is rude yeah because it's like
you could be like something to do with
like old
uh back in the day with concealed
weapons or something put your lap no i
would when i eat right my i've got my
hand like this and i got my hand down
here yeah under the table yeah like on
my on my whatever like yeah but i was
told that it's rude to do that in japan
really you have to have your hand like
this while you eat yes on the table i i
constantly got told by my mom to put my
hand on my table because yeah uh yeah it
goes back to that whole thing of back in
the old age where like if you had your
hand under the table then you could hide
a concealed weapon yeah and you could
just
so so when you're so when you're eating
with a modern problem yeah not a modern
problem obviously but like that's why
that's why you're seeing a lot of like
uh you know scenes in you know anime or
japanese tv or like old movies and stuff
like that that's why the other hand
they're usually holding the rice bowl or
holding a bowl or
having their hand on the table because
of that whole tradition i don't know why
it's not really a modern problem
nowadays but you know it's like having
tattoos in japan are like indicative of
the yakuza right supposedly even though
it didn't start with the yakuza it
started with firefighters what yeah
so when i interviewed the the ex-yakuza
member he obviously we got onto the
topic of tattoos right yeah because the
guy's [ __ ] covered in tats um and he
told me that originally
firefighters during the edo period would
get tattooed
and i was like why firefighters and it's
like so that if they die in a fire it's
easy to identify the body of god
and i'm like and it's like they put they
put it in there that took a [ __ ] time
and i'm like that took a [ __ ] dark
turn but then he put it into perspective
being like it's also just a matter of
like you having that tattoo back in the
older days that was an honor because
that just showed that was die undying
proof that you are doing a very
dangerous job to save other people's
lives yeah and like and for some reason
over the course of time with the yakuza
and like how you'd get tattooed when you
enter jail and stuff like that you know
as a mark it just slowly turned into
like a negative connotation to the point
where now today
any japanese person with like a [ __ ]
little tiny star tattoo on the back of
their palm is considered a yakuza member
you know and it's like it's just so and
it's gone to the point where like you
can't enter obviously hot springs it's
like it's like a common one yeah but you
can't even enter like public pools you
can't go to some beaches if you have
tattoos my dream like i mentioned was
anytime fitness right yeah yeah you
can't go to juice the only sign on the
wall that is in english is dear all
international members not even like
so you're all international members
please cover up any tattoos that you
might be showing and it's like and it's
weird because it's like you know think
about it logically just because you have
a tattoo it doesn't mean that person is
a [ __ ] psychopath or a yeah yeah yeah
but it's that whole mental image of oh
they're such a bad person because they
put some [ __ ] ink in their body that
you know it's it's this weird
stipulation of tattoo equals yakuza now
yeah
which is so dumb especially when it
comes it's the one i don't understand is
when that same rule applies to
foreigners here
yeah that is kind of odd yeah and i'm
like
you do realize yakuza is like a japan
thing only right guys it says a lot
about japanese society there's a lot
about it
says a lot about the absolute state
japanese society
wasn't funny yet here he is giving away
to himself saying it i'm not how the
tables have turned it's because we know
what this episode's gonna be five
million times this is what i'm saying
when me the memes that aren't funny
become funnier the more you just keep
saying it yeah squid game
so he just laughed he just left
no but
[Laughter]
[Music]
like i was just saying that he put into
like really interesting i mean i asked
him like what do you think about the
whole like tattoo stigma and he was like
oh it's [ __ ] stupid yeah like because
the the whole point of a yakuza tattoo
is we we put in tattoos not to show
people but to conceal it it's like a
massive difference the people who want
to show tattoos that's got nothing to do
with [ __ ] youngster yeah
isn't going to go around [ __ ] being
like check out my tats bro like they
don't do that
and until japanese people understand
that i don't think the stigma is ever
going to go away i'd like to think it's
starting to go away because young people
now in japan are getting tats and they
don't give a [ __ ]
do you think the new generation of japan
are more open to the idea of like
you know foreigners and just you know
things like ideas like death very much
so i mean japan has been americanized
for decades now almost centuries now and
yeah but like i feel it's only just
recently where they you know look at you
know american celebrities and singers
with you know who are covered in tats
and they go
if they can do that
maybe we can do that too
who the [ __ ] knew that maybe just
because you have a [ __ ] justin bieber
tattoo it doesn't make you a yakuza
member yeah because like um most of our
exposure to like japanese society comes
from the older generation right because
they have all the power in government so
i actually have no idea about what the
youths in japan are like thinking and
you know how much of
i mean you you walk down you know
shinjuku or shibuya any time of the day
or night and you'll see young people
covered in tats all the time you know
japanese people come in tats all the
time
i know this is kind of off topic but i
remember like someone told me that um
when uh avengers came out right and you
do press tours yeah apparently it was
really difficult for to for robert
downey jr to come here because he did a
criminal record in the u.s oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's just like
okay
i i mean i get it but but like i mean
but he's not doing it now yeah it's like
all right it just kind of shows that
it's like there's no there's no room for
but i mean i think
other countries are similar as well if
you have a criminal record yeah but it's
kind of like yeah but japan is
definitely the type of country where you
make one mistake you are dead to the
world oh yeah yeah and it's like it
doesn't matter how much it doesn't
matter how much you do to try and redeem
it or try and like change your image
that you're a better person you're a
fixed person now you make one mistake
you're [ __ ] but it's the one thing
that is really worrying is that like a
lot of the laws
and like punishment specifically sound
surrounding like
like creep crimes i'll say
like the crimes you know like being a
cheecan or being a pervert or being like
taking pictures of uh people in places
punishment have you seen how much how
little you have to pay yeah yeah some of
them are like 20 like 20 dollar fines
yeah yeah like 20
what's the point that's a saturday night
out with the boys
yeah
they're kidding me like they have so
many stalkers here because it's just so
bad you just face no repercussions for
like for like stalking someone that's
actually like it's actually like
because unfortunately in a lot of cases
in japan the if it's not a phys if it's
not physical harm that is a result of
the crime then it's not even considered
like they don't take into consideration
that you know you can be mentally
scarred for a crime and that's still
having real life repercussions because
they just think oh but did he touch you
did he stab you did he hurt you in any
way
you'll get over it it's like well no
because some people don't [ __ ] get
over it like it's pretty [ __ ]
traumatizing for some young women to get
you know creeped on getting their photos
taken most likely being leaked on the
internet without them knowing yeah and
then for the [ __ ] law system to turn
around and go yeah you'll get over it
because you ever nearly every single
japanese woman i spoke to had some
horrible experience of someone being a
pervert like nearly every japanese woman
and nearly pretty much every foreign
woman as well in japan yeah yeah has uh
has had a creepy experience i'm pretty
sure sydney has some as well yeah um
aki's definitely had some in it yeah
yeah horrible it's it's actually like
terrifying and
i you know it's it's [ __ ] up and i
don't know how to change it because it's
not even like it's not even our country
to change you know yeah but you know i
think i mean it was so weird for me
hearing the first time i you know you go
to japan
and if you buy a phone in japan there is
no silent option when you take a picture
if you if you buy a phone in japan no
matter what handset it is if it's a
japanese handset you cannot turn off the
sound
of the shutter when it takes a picture i
mean my phone is that
right
my phone's on silent right now
yeah that may just like that
yeah yeah and like
in in many ways you hear about that in
isolation you think well that's good you
know you're protecting people but it's
like what did it take for it to get to
that point yeah where we had to then
keep the shutter on like how rampant was
it and like you know the fact that japan
as far as i know is one of the only
countries on earth that has widespread
adoption of female only cars
yeah
only during a certain time though right
right right like which you know which i
feel completely takes away the point of
a female-only car if you ask me because
it's like oh then i just have to avoid
these times
that women would welcome that but it's
like it's like
you know for it to be done to and had
have to be done says a lot yeah and you
know about society and uh i wouldn't
like me personally i wouldn't want to
raise a daughter in japan i i would be
scared to death of like letting it go on
the train or something yeah well i think
the other problem as well is like
it's it's that a lot of the parents here
so and not that i'm trying to tell
japanese parents how to be parents but
like you know considering i'm not one
myself but i think the problem is that a
lot of the parents also just don't teach
their daughters
how what to do during those situations
right because they're like i feel like
you you ask any american parent or just
western parent you know like if their
daughter were to get into a horrible
situation like that to you know like
teach them some self-defense or you know
like try and defend themselves in any
way that they possibly can you know to
make a statement to be like i'm not
[ __ ] afraid of you yeah back off
right yeah in japan though they don't do
that no yeah because
there's no repercussions even if they
get caught yeah so they're just like if
i just ignore it then maybe it'll go
well but it doesn't if a guy is jacking
off to you on a train and you punch him
in the face in japan
because you're the one who initiated
physical violence exactly right so in
the eyes of the police you're the one
who initiated it um yeah it's it's weird
it's like you can make the argument of
oh it's self-defense but then the law
will turn around and go well he wasn't
technically hurting you and oh and also
do you have proof that he was you know
yeah doing these acts right yeah yeah
it's it's sad man it's really sad there
is a fundamental problem and just i
don't know like maybe they're trying to
change the law maybe they don't don't
give a [ __ ] i don't know but either way
it's messed up and it's more messed up
that again the parents are not teaching
i think there definitely needs to be
more protection for women here yeah it's
it's like it it is a thing women only
cars
is
minimum protection oh yeah exactly the
fact that we have to have min uh
women-only cars yeah it's it's it
shouldn't have gotten even
that's not a solution
and and yeah every pretty much every
female i've talked to has ha has had a
story you know has a story yeah there
was a tv show i was watching and it was
like literally called like like chican
hunters or something
and it was literally like a show where
like four undercover cops would just go
on a train and it was like this is just
real cameras and it was like gopro
footage but of course because it's
interesting chris hansen japan yeah so
but of course it's in japan right so
everything is censored you literally
cannot see anything the whole cause
they're on a train with a gopro because
of japan they don't like to show people
on tv yeah you can't see anything in
this train yeah they've blurred it out
right but to distinguish who the pervert
is and who the victim is they're just
blue blurs and a pink blur
right and you can't see what's going on
yeah it's absolutely what's your tv i
think it was maybe three tokyo
gbs
tbs i don't know which channel it was i
only really watched like three i don't
watch nhk nhk is boring
but it was like
first of all i was like this is terrible
production this is awful
but
they found like four dudes doing this in
like one day yeah in like the same like
car and it's like what the [ __ ]
and they would like they would have to
get camera footage of them doing it like
multiple times yeah so to prove that it
wasn't an accident because they could do
the whole bump and touch their ass but
they would have to like catch them
multiple times and then i don't know
what they did i i assumed they just gave
them like a slap on the wrist or
something but they wouldn't show their
face or anything
and uh it was just like you wonder
you're like well clearly like this
punishment isn't effective like if you
shamed them for doing it would it would
it help a little bit but it's also like
is it fair to ruin someone life over
that i don't know probably not but like
it's weird also there was like 20 cops
for like one dude touching a girl's ass
tree
i was like i think you don't need this
many naps i think one maybe two i think
i think i think two cops can handle one
one pervert i think i think it's okay i
know that you need like that the dude is
not like nine feet tall and like 500
pounds i think i think one person can
handle it it's crazy right so they have
the four undercover detectives on this
train right they they find the guy they
come out and then there's like eight
more police escorting this one guy
[ __ ] and it's like
i get it like it's yeah you gotta arrest
him you want some backup i i totally
understand but like how much do you need
like come on like how much taxpayer
money is going towards that there's 12
dudes arresting them i mean there's
probably you know to some of those cops
it's like oh finally my first actual job
bro the fine doesn't even cover his walk
from the train to the [ __ ] train
holding room like the the police time
wasted doesn't even cover the fine they
gave this dude yeah it's a joke it's
[ __ ] stupid as [ __ ] it's like you
know i i'm sure if we went through uk
police or or any uk laws or
australian laws i'm sure we could find
another 10 000 million things to
criticize about we're in japan and you
know there's what's what what's on our
mind
bro that was a that was a societal deep
conversation
this is what this episode did say a lot
about society
this one said a lot about how society's
kind of like squid game huh who knew
that one of the deepest uh trash days
episodes to date started with
a shitty meme that makes no sense
says a lot about others who says a lot
about society says a lot about society
dear viewers do you like it when we talk
about hashtag deep stuff or we get into
hashtag deep stuff hashtag hashtag more
you know less surface level debate i
think hashtag real stuff yeah real stuff
do you like it
i think i think we have a nice nice
nice balance now we started talking
about
anime talking about foodies that lasted
what five minutes
you know i i i like that trash taste is
light-hearted and fun but you know
sometimes i do like talking about some
some things that are not not so fun
yeah you know exactly because it's i'm
human it's an interesting conversation
to have i think you know and especially
when done we need more people to talk
about society exactly we need more
societies because society is saying a
lot
so
no one else says
our patients says a lot about society
that we have all these wonderful
supporters supporting the show
this this goes hard feel free to
screenshot this image this guy he says a
lot about society
my brain is running yeah man but hey if
you like to support the show then make
sure to go to our patreon patreon.com
also follow us on twitter send us your
memes on the subreddit and if you hate
our face listen to us on spotify
but uh yeah this was a deep societal
talk hopefully we can have many more we
will say about we are going to go back
into society now and uh hope you guys
enjoy your time in society too so uh
feel free to scream
bye
[Music]
foreign